Ich muss mir jetzt aber noch mal kurz
ein neues T-Shirt anziehen.
Ich bin gerade gerannt.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Wieder.
Jetzt aber.
Oh, ich muss mein Headset wieder umstecken,
weil es rauscht, Leute.
Ich habe das wieder zurückgestöpselt.
Warte mal.
Ich stöpsel mal um.
Dass es wieder besser klingt.
Und zwar
musste ich, ja.
Da mute ich euch mal kurz,
weil sonst macht es gleich
jetzt besser.
So, jetzt machen wir den Sound
noch mal ein bisschen leiser.
Ich habe noch nichts eingestellt.
Ich bin heute
8. Ich sage es euch.
ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Kurz Lautstärke einstellen.
Okay.
Ja, so ist gut.
Alles klar. So, auf geht's.
Ja, weil
ich bin heute
58, 59 Minuten
bin ich heute
gerannt. 8,25 Kilometer.
Das heißt
im Durchschnitt ungefähr 7 Minuten
pro Kilometer
mit 153
und 53 Puls.
Ich bin absichtlich
ein bisschen langsamer gerannt,
da ich nicht komplett im Arsch bin.
Aber nachdem das halt
knapp eine Stunde gedauert hat
und ich erst 7 Uhr
45 oder so losgerannt bin,
war ich auch.
Also ich bin quasi die 8 Uhr
1,50 oder so die Treppe hoch.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
Mist, jetzt musst du eigentlich gleich Stream anmachen.
Du musst dich aber auch noch umziehen
ums Klo.
Deswegen war ich jetzt erst mal
5 Minuten AFK.
Moin.
Der Gelnhausen Dude ist wieder am Start.
Da wollte ich letztens sogar.
Nee, Moment, sorry, ich verwechsel.
Da wollte ich nicht hin.
Ich wollte nach Wiesbaden.
Da ist so ein Fahrradladen,
wo ich was gucken wollte.
Wobei in Gelnhausen bestimmt auch.
Gibt ja überall welche.
Ja, Leute, ich habe mir ernsthaft überlegt,
ich hole mir noch ein Fahrrad.
Irgendwie, irgendwie habe ich es jetzt
mit mit Bewegungs-Champ.
Bald gibt's, bald gibt's Fitness-Champ.
Neue App.
Von mir.
Wobei Fitness-Champ ist viel zu, viel zu 0815.
Das müsste Movement-Champ oder so was Dummes heißen.
Sport-Champ.
Nee, Plötzchen.
Aber irgendwie, irgendwie habe ich es jetzt so.
Und ich meine, hey, solange noch, solange noch gutes Wetter ist,
macht das ja auch noch mal, macht das ja auch noch mal mehr Bock.
Das ist sehr gut zu wissen.
Das ist, das ist, das ist wirklich gut zu wissen.
Hm.
Also ich, ich bin, ich bin gerade so ein bisschen am gucken,
was ich mir holen will.
Aber wenn du in einem, wenn du in einem Bike-Shop arbeitest, fährst,
du fährst bestimmt ja auch selber.
Also, was würdest du mir denn raten, wenn ich sagen würde,
ich will hauptsächlich, nee, nee, nee, kein E-Bike, kein E-Bike.
Also ich will, ich will hauptsächlich Fahrrad fahren.
So eine Mischung aus ganz normal eben auf Fahrradweg,
aber auch mal so den einen oder anderen Waldweg.
Mit so ein bisschen Schotter.
Da gibt es ja so, so all in, all in one, all round Bikes.
Und da habe ich allerdings gelesen,
dass das alles zurzeit enorm schlecht lieferbar ist.
Das kann auch ruhig ein bisschen was kosten.
Ich will keinen Kack, ja.
Nee, das, das ist wieder zum geradeaus lange.
Also ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt geguckt.
Die Kategorie nennt sich, glaube ich, Gravel Bike.
Das heißt ja so viel wie Kies, glaube ich.
Ich meine, übersetzt wird es, glaube ich, mit Schotter.
Aber ich glaube direkt, ich glaube direkt heißt es Kies, oder?
Was heißt das auf Deutsch?
Kies, ja.
Alle wollen günstig los.
Ja, soll mir recht sein.
Also ich, ich würde schon mir gern was Gescheites kaufen.
Die Dinge aus der Trimax Fahrradtour.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der, was, was hat Trimax denn auf seiner Fahrradtour gefahren?
Die sind doch nicht E-Bike gefahren, oder?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie eine Fahrradtour gemacht haben.
Ich kenne, ich kenne nur noch, ich kenne nur noch die, die Longboardtour.
Kennt noch irgendjemand die Longboardtour?
Ich habe das, ich habe das damals nie so großartig verfolgt.
Aber natürlich, man hat ja mitbekommen.
Man hat es ja mitbekommen.
Ich gucke jetzt gerade mal bei Bildern.
Wo sind die noch?
Was für ein Fahrrad, Alter.
Was zum Teufel sind die denn da rumgefahren?
Na gut, es war wahrscheinlich, dass sie ein bisschen mehr Gepäck mitnehmen können.
Guck mal hier.
Trimax, Fahrrad, WTF.
Na, sowas will ich nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass sie massig Gepäck mitnehmen können, oder?
Hatten die da auch noch, hatten die da auch noch, hatten die da irgendwie noch, ist da noch ein Akku drin und ein Motor?
Ja, aber warum nicht?
Man muss immer das Richtige nehmen für den richtigen Zweck.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Bestimmt wurden die von, ähm, garantiert, garantiert.
Die haben 100 Pro, das ist ja eine super Gelegenheit für alle.
Ja.
So, und wie gesagt, ich bin mir gerade am überlegen noch ein Fahrrad zu kaufen.
Aber da muss man ja schon so mit.
Du hast dir das, du hast dir das gekauft.
Sowas in der Richtung habe ich auch schon geguckt.
Aber nicht das, das ist ja quasi so ein reines Rennrad, oder?
Nee, das ist, äh, kein Rennrad.
Kein, das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was das für eins ist.
Ein Crossbike Fitness.
Ja, das sind die Dinger, wo du, wo du die dir auch mal tragen kannst.
Zumindest muss man da, wenn ich mir das hier schon angucke, also auch in andere Richtungen muss man da schon durchaus mal mit 2000 Euro rechnen, ja.
Und was witzig ist, dass die ganzen Fahrräder keine Pedale haben.
Aber ist auch klar, weil das wohl was sehr Individuelles ist.
Die Leute da haben wollen.
Aha.
So, dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken, was geht denn so auf, auf Fithub ab.
Und diese Woche ist einiges passiert, Leute.
Ich habe gehört, AVM will unter den Hammer Gachibas.
AVM will sich, will sich verkaufen.
Bestimmt, bestimmt am Ende an irgendwelcher Stelle.
Bestimmt am Ende an irgendwelche China-Chinesen oder so.
BlackHD, dankeschön für den Sub.
Und hier, wen haben wir noch?
Ne, haben wir keinen.
Exzellent.
Gut, ich hatte doch schon was vergessen.
Trinken.
Ich muss mir unbedingt gleich neuen Tee holen.
Ist fast leer.
Und ich habe laut App, ich habe laut App 8,25 Kilometer habe ich verbraucht an Schweiß 982 Milliliter.
Also ich habe gerade ungefähr ein Kilo, ein Kilo Wasser rausgeschwitzt.
Also ich muss gleich mal ein bisschen was nachfüllen.
Oh, was ist das?
Meine App meint Congratulations.
New Achieve, was Moment mein, Englisch, Englischsatz.
Congratulations on achieving a new personal best.
Okay, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was mein new personal best ist, weil ich war wirklich nicht schnell unterwegs heute.
Ah, longest run.
8,8 Kilometer 25.
Okay, okay.
Ja, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es ein Achievement in der App ist.
Aber dann accepten wir mal das Achievement.
Nächster, nächster Meilenstein ist 10 Kilometer durchhalten.
Und dann bin ich, dann bin ich zufrieden.
Das ist wirklich, die App ist wirklich ganz gut gemacht.
Dann bin ich zufrieden, wenn ich 10 Kilometer schaffe, dann mehr, mehr muss es nicht sein.
Also mein, mein, also mein mittelfristiges Ziel ist, dass ich 10 Kilometer schaffe unter
6 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Aktuell, aktuell schaffe ich 5 Kilometer unter 6 Minuten, also unter, nicht unter 6 Minuten,
also unter 6 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Also das heißt 5 Minuten, mein Rekord ist glaube ich gerade 5, 5 Kilometer in 29 Minuten 37.
Also müsste ich quasi unter 60 Minuten, also 10 Kilometer unter 60 Minuten.
Das ist so das, was ich.
Jetzt erstmal.
Also näherer Zukunft auf die Reihe kriegen will.
Dann, dann ist es erstmal gut.
Nächstes Jahr Frankfurt Marathon, ja ganz bestimmt.
Nein, nicht Fahrrad.
Nicht Fahrrad.
Mit Fahrrad wäre das ganz schön lahm.
Fahrrad habe ich ja auch noch keins.
Kann ich auch noch nicht fahren.
Also ja.
So, also bann, Trended.
Ja, das müssen wir uns demnächst auch mal angucken.
Javascript.
Das kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut es sein soll.
Ist bann mit NPM kompatibel?
Weil das ist ja eigentlich eines der größten Pluspunkte des Javascript Ökosystems,
dass es für fast jeden Furz irgendeine Library gibt.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass JetBrains eine Rust IDE rausgebracht hat?
Nein, aber das finde ich sehr nice.
Wie heißt es?
Rust Mine?
Oder was?
Rust.
Die Rust Rover.
Na gut, Rust Mine wäre ja auch ziemlich bescheuert.
Die gibt es ja schon bei Ruby.
Also, dem passt so Rust nicht.
Rust Rover.
Eine brandneue JetBrains IDE für Rust Entwickler.
Das gucken wir uns mal kurz an, das Video.
Das gucken wir uns mal kurz an, was das Tolles kann.
Wann kam denn das?
Das ist das schon eine ganze Weile.
Ist schon ein bisschen älter, gell?
Aber das ist gut.
Das dürfte Rust auf jeden Fall noch mal in Ordnung.
Weil ich glaube, eines der nervigsten Sachen in Rust,
neben äußerst komplexer Syntax und auch echt ein bisschen Einstiegs,
wie soll man sagen, hohe Lernkurve,
ist die IDE-Experience.
Du hattest zwar bisher schon die ganzen JetBrains,
beziehungsweise IntelliJ-Plugins, die ganz okay waren.
In Visual Studio Code ging es auch halbwegs gescheit.
Also wirklich gut empfand ich da als nichts,
wo ich da bisher mit rumgeblieben bin.
Wo ich da bisher mit rumgebastelt habe.
Heißt im Endeffekt, das dürfte noch mal richtig was bringen.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was das Ding kann.
Rust.
Rewrite in Rust.
Placingly fast.
Okay, ich finde schon mal gut, dass die keinen Sound haben.
Das ist schon mal nice.
Können wir hier mit Skadoodle laufen lassen.
Was ich auch cool finde, dass die keinen Sound haben,
weil normalerweise hast du in diesen Werbevideos
oder vielleicht ist ja auch nur mal ein Browser,
der keinen Sound abspielen kann.
Wobei.
Ne, das ist Chrome.
Chrome kann auf jeden Fall sein.
Chrome kann auf jeden Fall Sound abspielen.
Oder vielleicht haben die irgendeinen Codec,
den nur Firefox kann.
Das glaube ich jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ne, die haben einfach keinen Sound.
Was ich persönlich nicht schlecht finde,
weil diese ganzen Werbevideos,
die haben immer alle diesen gleichen Werbevideos-Sound.
Weißt du, also dieses super fröhliche,
belanglose Hintergrundgeklimper.
Die haben alle fast den gleichen Sound,
die ganzen Werbevideos.
So.
Rust.
Blazingly fast.
Clap.
Das kenne ich sogar.
Das ist ein Command-Line-Parser,
der mich fast zur Verzweiflung gebracht hat.
Jira-Service startet.
Pog.
Du machst Jira.
Ihr habt ein Ticketsystem im Fahrradshop.
Ja, stimmt.
Warum nicht?
Ich meine, je nachdem, wie groß das ist.
Jira.
Das ist gut, dass die hier direkte
Crate- und Cargo-Gedönsunterstützung haben,
weil Rust ist halt so ein Ding,
du brauchst halt für jedes Rust-Projekt gefühlt 80 Packages.
Okay, nice.
Ordentliches Autocomplete, was nicht abkackt nach einer Zeit,
dürfte wahrscheinlich echt das Beste sein.
Mich würde mal interessieren, auf was die aufsetzen.
Ob die auf diesen Rust-Language-Services,
oder wie das heißt, aufsetzen,
oder ob die da wieder quasi alles verarbeiten,
quasi alles fast selbst drumherum gestrickt haben.
Bei .NET ist es ja so halbe-halbe.
Die benutzen Microsoft-Zeug,
allerdings haben sie sehr viel drumherum gestrickt.
Beispielsweise, äh,
Lautstärke der Playlist ist auch extremely pepega.
Da haben sie ja bei .NET auch viel drumherum gestrickt.
Da haben sie ihr ReSharper-Zeug genommen,
haben noch einen eigenen Debugger und alles drumherum gebaut für Rider,
weil das Microsoft-Zeug sich nicht gescheit integrieren ließ.
Ähm, Browser, ich hätte das gerne im Fullscreen.
Okay, Refactor, Rename.
Okay.
Rust-Dinger.
Die Rust-Syntax ist teilweise schon echt ein bisschen abartig, ne?
Hier mit Testrunner dabei.
Okay, nice.
Direkt Integration von Backend-Web-Server-Gedöns
finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Kannste nachgucken, welcher Request auf welchem Breakpoint trifft.
Gut.
Die üblichen JetBrains-Shit-Features,
die ich nicht verwende,
weil Command-Line-Git einzig wahre, beste
und jeder, der was anderes nutzt, highly pepega.
Weil ich das so sag.
Ja, nicht schlecht.
Könnt man sich tatsächlich demnächst mal geben.
So, also.
Was trendet denn
diese Woche?
BAM!
Ja, wie gesagt.
Das müssen wir uns mal bei Gelegenheit angucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, hat BAM, hat da jemand was draufgegeben?
Ist BAM NPM-Packages kompatibel?
Aha.
Okay, nice.
Das ist ein riesen Vorteil.
Warum das Deno nicht von Anfang an hatte, verstehe ich nicht.
Aber das ist gut.
Weil eines der riesen, größten Vorteile von
dem gesamten JavaScript-Ökosystem ist ja eben die Package-Anzahl.
Und natürlich auch ist odd und ist even.
Wie kann man ohne die essentiellsten NPM-Packages überhaupt programmieren?
So, Java-Zeug, AI.
Game Engine.
Wo ich mir sagen lassen habe, dass man das Godo ausspricht und nicht Godot.
Ich dachte immer, es heißt Godot.
Weil ich mir das nie angeguckt habe und dachte, es ist halt in Go programmiert.
Bis ich mir das irgendwann mal angeschaut habe, habe ich festgestellt,
nee, das hat mit Go überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Nicht eine Zeile Go in dem gesamten Projekt.
Unity ist dead.
Stimmt, das war die Woche auch noch, dass Unity ihre Lizenzbedingungen geändert hat.
Irgendwie retroaktiv für schon veröffentlichte Games ab dem 01.01.2024 und sowas.
Alter, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
was denkt sich der Unity-CEO?
Denkt er sich irgendwie so, ey, Speedrun zu Company Sale?
So nach dem Motto, nice, da kriege ich nochmal fett Millionen und habe ausgesorgt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was dort dahinter gedankt ist.
Ja, kann er ja auch verstehen.
Ich weiß echt nicht, was sie sich dabei vorstellen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein Ex-EAC.
Ja gut, das ist doch egal, wo der herkommt.
Ich meine, du kannst ja erwarten, dass er sinnige Entscheidungen trifft.
Das heißt, er ist der Meinung.
Es ist eine sinnvolle Entscheidung.
Und da muss man sich immer auch mal in die andere Rolle hineinversetzen.
Überlegt, warum könnte das eine sinnvolle Entscheidung sein?
Und es ist eine sinnvolle Entscheidung.
Und ich meine, da gibt es ja mehrere Gründe.
Entweder, weil er kurzfristig noch ein bisschen Geld rauspressen will,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Weil er vielleicht wirklich will, dass man das Ding verkauft
und er fett Kohle nochmal machen kann.
Oder weiß es nicht, ja.
Da kann man sich viel überlegen.
Aber der hat bestimmt seinen Grund.
Der macht das bestimmt nicht einfach so random komplett.
Wie gesagt, das könnte durchaus sein, dass der, ähm,
will das, vor allem, wenn er das verkauft, kriegt er wahrscheinlich nochmal richtig fett Kohle.
Das stimmt auch nur halb.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Das ist aber auch so ein typisches Ding, wo man News und Kommentaren in News nicht so hundertprozentig vertrauen kann.
Und zwar, ja, das stimmt, dass die ihre Aktien verkauft haben.
Aber es ist nicht so, als hätten die einen Tag, bevor sie die Ankündigung gemacht haben,
ohne es jemals jemand zu sagen, ihre Aktien verkauft.
Weil wenn du CEO bist von einem Unternehmen und willst einen größeren...
Und er hat auch gar nicht alle seine Stocks verkauft,
sondern irgendwie plus, keine Ahnung, fünf Prozent oder so.
Ähm, das mussten die im Vorfeld ankündigen.
Und das haben die auch im Vorfeld angekündigt, weil die sonst richtig Ärger wahrscheinlich mit dem Finanzamt oder sowas bekommen hätten.
Und dementsprechend ist das...
Stimmt das so, wie das hervorgehoben wurde in Posts und News und Comments gar nicht so richtig?
Also die mussten das, die mussten das bekannt geben.
Ich glaube, irgendwie drei Wochen oder so vorher schon.
Natürlich wusste man nicht warum.
Okay, aber...
Ja, und das war es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das war wahrscheinlich nicht...
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass da irgendjemand für den Knast kommt, weil die es sicherlich rechtlich korrekt gemacht haben.
So, also was haben wir denn sonst noch hier auf Shithub?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, klingt aber irgendwie nach AI, oder?
Diffenbier.
Man hat keine Ahnung, was es ist, aber bestimmt AI.
Wenn man nicht weiß, was es ist, ist es AI.
Ja.
Haha.
Haha, recht.
So sieht es aus, AI.
Der Repo-Name ist auch AI-generated.
Ja, neue Programmiersprache, das ist dieses C++-Python-Ding.
Wo mir persönlich nichts zugesagt hat, weil nichts Open Source davon ist.
Von der Sprache.
Und wo ich mich frage, wie kann das 2023 überhaupt sein?
Schon merkwürdig, oder?
AI, AI.
China, China-Chinesen-AI.
Also, wenn AI noch getoppt werden kann, dann nur noch von China-Chinesen-AI.
De Compilatores.
Okay, alles klar.
Rust.
AI.
Stimmt, auch AI.
Irgendwas für AirTags, vermutlich.
Apple Bluetooth-Lauter.
Apple Bluetooth-Low-Energy.
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch, was AirTags verwenden.
Oder?
Doch, relativ sicher.
Ernährungs-Pairing-Message-Spoofing.
Warum? Weshalb?
Okay, hier gibt es schon wieder irgendwelchen Beef.
Kann man dann ein ESP32 pairen als AirTag oder sowas?
React Native.
Wir haben...
AI, AI, AI.
Baird.
Ein FITZ 2 Backbone with Baird.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
TL Draw.
Very good Whiteboard.
Leute, hier.
Porgas Whiteboard.
Massive.
Was sagt es zu dem neuen iPhone 15 Pro?
Ich habe nur gelesen, dass das angekündigt wurde und wieder ultra teuer ist.
Aber damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt...
Also, ich hätte auch nicht mit nichts anderem gerechnet.
Stehen jetzt eigentlich die Kameras da so weit raus, wie man ursprünglich vermutet hat?
Ich habe mir das...
Ich habe mir das nicht...
Nicht weiter...
Ich habe nur gelesen, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Ja, ne?
Die Kameras gucken noch weiter raus als gedacht.
Also, das alte liegt schon nur noch mit...
Nur noch mit...
Gehäuse halbwegs flach auf dem Tisch.
Also...
Ich meine, ich darf nichts sagen.
Ich habe mir auch einen...
iPhone...
Was habe ich denn überhaupt?
iPhone Pro, glaube ich, geholt.
Aber nicht Max und sonst was.
Das ging doch.
Ich glaube, ich habe 1200 Euro bezahlt.
Und das ist auch schon mega krass dämlich teuer.
Wie gefällt dir Baldur's Gate 3?
Also, ich habe es noch nicht durch.
Der dritte Akt lässt extrem nach.
In allen Bereichen.
Story.
Polishing.
Bugs.
Genereller...
Flow.
Dialoge.
Sachen, an was man gedacht hat.
Der dritte Akt ist wirklich noch ziemlich unfinished.
Insgesamt muss ich sagen...
Ich finde Baldur's Gate 3 ist ein gutes Game geworden.
Aber Baldur's Gate 3 ist nicht das beste Game ever made.
Das beste RPG ever made oder sonst was.
Wie das teilweise in Reviews geschrieben wird.
Die wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden oder so gespielt haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich finde Baldur's Gate 3 ist viel zu leicht.
Und ich finde nicht alle Anpassungen, gerade was Kämpfe angeht, super gelungen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein nice Game.
Ich glaube Baldur's Gate 3 ist fast eher was für Leute, die auf ausgefeilte Dialoge und Konsequenzen daraus und Entscheidungen stehen.
Weniger auf Fights.
Also ich muss sagen, in Kämpfen selbst ist Baldur's Gate 3 gar nicht mal so gut.
Also alle die auf Dungeons & Dragons möglichst original stehen, kommen in Baldur's Gate 3 auf jeden Fall nicht auf ihre Kosten.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ich finde es muss ein Game auch nicht.
Was auch schon die ersten Baldur's Gate Icewind Dales nicht hatten.
Die waren auch schon teilweise recht weit weg von der Vorlage.
Das ist aber auch nicht schlimm.
Aber dafür ist es wieder zu gut.
es wieder zu nah an der Vorlage,
weil beispielsweise bei kaum
einem Level-Up irgendwas passiert.
Also Character Progression hat
Baldur's Gate 3
sehr verhalten, ja.
Da ist es tatsächlich am nächsten an der Vorlage
dran, weil Level-Ups
machen kaum einen Unterschied.
Bis auf manche Key-Level,
ja, aber ansonsten passiert da nicht
pro Level-Up. Also das war in Divinity
tatsächlich deutlich PC-Spiel
freundlicher.
Also für jemand, der diesen
Dialog-Role-Playing-
Aspekt mag,
ist Baldur's Gate 3 nice.
Es ist für alle zu empfehlen,
die gerne RPGs spielen,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht das
beste RPG ever made oder sowas,
wo sie sich da teilweise ereifert haben
überall. Auch
muss sehr viel, und das kann man ihnen jetzt aber nicht
vorwerfen, weil letztendlich müssen wir das Produkt bewerten,
was rausgekommen ist.
Letztendlich muss sehr viel Content
fehlen, der noch angekündigt
war. Beispielsweise fehlen ganze
Stadtviertel in Baldur's Gate
und wo es teilweise auch massig
Content schon gab. Im Early Access,
der wohl gestrichen wurde, aber gut, letztendlich ist
ihre Entscheidung, wie sie es rausbringen.
Muss halt passen. Ich muss
ehrlich sagen, die Story hat mich nicht abgeholt
von Baldur's Gate 3.
Ich glaube, das ist aber so ein typischer Fall,
man mag es oder man hasst es.
Ich fand den Mind Flayer
in D&D noch nie sonderlich,
weiß ich,
irgendwie spannend.
Auch wenn es ein recht großer
Lore-Teil ist.
Craigie, danke schön für den Sub.
Und
es ist viel zu viel Fokus auf diese
ganze Mind Flayer-Geschichte.
Der eigentliche, ich werde jetzt
nicht spoilern, aber der eigentliche Story-Twist
so Ende Akt 2
hat man irgendwie
schon ein bisschen kommen sehen,
was hinter dem
Absolut steckt.
Aber das
fand ich noch ganz gut,
aber es ist mir zu viel Mind Flayer gedöhnt.
Und auch sehr langsam.
Im Prinzip ist die Story von Baldur's Gate 3
echt, die kannst du in der
Seite zusammenfassen, easy.
Oder in halbem Seite, easy zusammenfassen.
Ich fand die jetzt nicht sonderlich.
Da fand ich ja, da fand ich viele
Side-Quests und Storys tatsächlich
interessanterer.
Interessanter.
Es ist ein gutes Game.
Ja, wäre halt aber auch kein
guter Abschluss gewesen. Akt 2 Ende war
tatsächlich ziemlich nice.
Ich weiß nicht.
Doch, Baldur's Gate 3 ist das
einsteigerfreundlichste, so
Classic-RPG der letzten Jahre.
Das ist das
einfachste und beste, wie du einsteigen kannst.
Die haben sogar halbwegs
gute Pre-Made-Characters diesmal.
Ich hab nichts gespoilert.
Akt 2 Ende
war aber echt nice.
Also ist auf jeden Fall einsteigerfreundlich.
Mir fällt eigentlich kein einsteigerfreundliches
so Classic-RPG ein,
aber ich muss sagen, Divinity
ist auf jeden Fall schwieriger.
Gerade auf höherem, also es ist
nicht nur schwieriger, sondern auf höherem
Schwierigkeitsgrad deutlich schwieriger.
Man muss wissen, was man
macht.
Ich persönlich,
wobei in Baldur's Gate 3
ist alles Voice-Acted, aber es ist halt
viel Dialog, das stimmt. Also ich muss
ehrlich sagen, wenn ich
Gameplay-technisch
die Auswahl hätte zwischen Baldur's Gate 3
und Pathfinder,
Wrath of the Righteous, würde ich sagen, Pathfinder.
Gameplay-technisch.
Ich mag
Realtime with Paws
und
das gesamte Charakter-Tweaken
optimieren auf höherem Schwierigkeitsgrad
ist Pathfinder einfach
nahezu unerreicht. Pathfinder ist
auch ziemlich unfertig im letzten Akt.
Wird sich wahrscheinlich, außer vielleicht noch durch
richtig große Modgis, nichts mehr dran ändern.
Die haben ja schon so eine Premium-Edition rausgebracht.
Aber das hat
nicht so viel geändert.
Der letzte Akt ist auch ziemlich
unfertig, aber das scheint ja mittlerweile fast
normal zu sein.
Wohingegen Baldur's Gate 1
hatte einen richtig guten, das war eigentlich fast
das Beste am Game, der letzte Akt.
Naja, ich würde halt
sagen, rein für
Dialoge, Role-Playing
und
Auswahl, die man
hat und Konsequenzen daraus, dann würde
ich sagen Spiral Skate 3
schon besser.
Und wenn irgendjemand mal wirklich
relativ rolling Dungeons & Dragons
Fifth Edition Rules spielen will,
der soll sich mal so Luster angucken.
Der soll sich mal so Luster angucken.
Das ist mehr oder weniger,
WÖRTLICH,
Außer dass die Charaktere halt mega beschissen aussehen,
Das ist eher mehr oder weniger wörtlich
Die ähm
Ja, Dungeons & Dragons
fünfte Aussage consciente Regeln,
natürlich auch bescheuerte, bescheuerte Screenshots
umgesetzt in einem PC-Spiel.
Also Lassa ist wirklich
nice für jemand, der mal die
Raw Dungeons & Dragons Experience
in einem PC-Spiel haben will.
Man kann nicht
die Story und nicht das
Production Value erwarten von
einem Baldur's Gate. Und die
Charakter-Models sehen teilweise schon echt
bescheuert aus.
Es ist
Gameplay-technisch, Fight-mäßig
wirklich ziemlich nah dran.
An der Vorlage.
Ich muss mir gleich einen neuen Tee holen.
So, hatten wir jetzt eigentlich
Shit-Hub fertig geguckt? Ich glaube schon, gell?
Ja, wir hatten Shit-Hub fertig geguckt.
Lass uns nochmal ganz schnell durch
scrollen.
Was es in der .NET-Welt gibt.
Und Dapper-Keckel, wer benutzt denn das?
Remote-Uni-Hackers, Steam-Tools.
Maui.
Wisst ihr was?
Es ist schade,
dass man nicht auf Software-Projekte
irgendwie wetten kann.
Ich bin ja kein großer Glücksspiel-Fan, aber es gibt so ein paar
Sachen, da würde ich gerne drauf wetten.
Und ich würde zum Beispiel gerne drauf wetten,
dass innerhalb der nächsten 2-3
Jahre Maui eingestellt
wird von Microsoft.
Weil es keine Sau verwendet und suckt.
Und Microsoft bekannt dafür ist,
UI-Frameworks einfach abzusägen.
Nachdem es noch eine Woche zuvor
als das beste
seit geschnitten Brot oder Erfindung des Rats
verkauft wurde.
Irgendwelche Maui-User hier im Chat.
Also schauen wir mal in Bylight, ja?
Und falls ja, wie findet ihr es?
Außer Buggy ist fuck.
Und kein Linux-Support.
Dann lieber Avalonia, wenn es sein muss.
Spannendes drin.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon gesehen habt.
Windows Forms, ja, mit Windows Forms
kommt man ja auch klar, wenn es Windows-only und kurz und knackig
sein soll.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gesehen habt, aber
AVM, also Fritzbox-Hersteller,
und Fritzphone, und
Fritzsmart, und
also alles Fritz, Fritziche,
die wollen sich selbst
verkaufen.
Weil, also eins der Hauptgründe muss
wohl sein, weil die Gründer mittlerweile irgendwie
an die 70 sind und nicht wissen, wie lange sie es noch
machen und wie lange
sie das noch durchhalten.
Keine Ahnung. Ich frage mich auch, warum
sie keinen Nachfolger finden, die AVM
weiterführt wie bisher. Weil man muss
ja sagen, AVM läuft es ja wohl ganz
gut. In Zukunft
muss man halt mal schauen, wenn DSL
weniger relevant wird
und
wenn man für Glasfaser
mehr oder weniger jeden
0815 besseren Router
benutzen kann mit einem
SFP Plus
Port, falls das so sein
wird. Mal gucken.
Aber trotzdem braucht man ja noch Zusatzfunktionen
wie beispielsweise die Deck-Basis-Station
und ich finde, gerade was Thermostate
angeht, ist Fritzzeug nicht schlecht.
Ich... Ja, das kann sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, weil
bei mir wird es wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit
mit Ausbau auch nichts, weil wir ja schon Gigabit-Kabel
haben und irgendjemand hat sich überlegt, ach nee,
dann...
Dann erstmal später Glasfaser.
Obwohl, witzigerweise, Hanau, passt mal
auf, passt mal auf, Hanau,
Fiber to the Home. Was witzig ist,
dass...
Da sieht man mal wieder, dass einfach
politisch so viel Bullshit
erzählt wird.
Warte mal, wie geht das nochmal,
mit Google-Search-Filter.
Beliebige Zeit,
Zeitraum festlegen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal,
ja, wir gucken jetzt mal,
nee, bis,
bis,
von irgendwas bis 2002.
Naja, das ist noch zu früh. Es hat nämlich
vor Jahren mal
der Oberbürgermeister
von Hanau großspurig
erzählt, wir werden in
drei Jahren oder so, hier,
was kann denn sein?
Nee, das ist...
Großspurig erzählt,
ja,
2015,
ich find's jetzt nicht.
Da haben sie groß erzählt,
dass es ausgebaut wird und dass wir
bis 2020 flächendeckend
Fiber to the Home haben. Und damals
hab ich mir schon gedacht,
...
Avm möchte sich
verkaufen.
Ob das jetzt gut ist für
uns
als Leute, die
AVM Geräte kaufen
möchten in Zukunft, vielleicht
weiß man nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich wird das an irgendeinen
Geldgebergruppe
verkauft und
die
Die pressen noch das letzte an Kohle raus und verkaufen es dann weiter.
Und dann geht es den Bach runter.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ja, und was es diese Woche auch noch als Aufreger gab, war diese Unity-Geschichte.
Okay, die Leute übertreiben es aber auch immer.
Meine Fresse, Alter.
Sollen sie den Kram halt nicht über...
Die übertreiben es immer, Mann.
Ja, und weil Unity gesagt hat, ab 1.1. wollen sie dann auch für schon veröffentlichte Spiele Gebühren verlangen.
Da gehe ich ja eigentlich auch mal von aus, aber man weiß es nicht.
Moment, Moment.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, bei mir gibt es schon Gigabit-Kabel und deswegen wird das wahrscheinlich mit Ausbau in nächster Zeit nichts.
Das ist ja nichts, was ich jetzt sagen würde.
Weißt du, es ist ja nicht so, als ruft die Telekom bei mir an und sagt,
Max, wir würden dir gerne Fiber to the Home...
...legen und ich sage, nee, nee, ich habe Kabel.
Das wird auf der Ebene entschieden, dass ich gar nichts dazu sagen darf.
Da wird geguckt, in dem Gebiet gibt es ja schon Kabel, Gigabit, also bauen wir dort nicht aus.
Es ist nicht so, als hätte ich da irgendwas zu sagen zu...
Weiß ich nicht.
Das wäre ja lustig.
Moment, Moment.
Unity.
Update.
Wo ist das Update?
Ihr habt es verkackt.
Ja, steht nichts dazu da.
Aber...
Na ja, komm, wir gucken jetzt nicht weiter.
Ropsen.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Wie gesagt, ich habe gerade gelesen, dass es Morddrohungen gegeben hat für Unity,
aber ob das die von Mitarbeitern sein sollen, habe ich nirgendwo gelesen bisher.
Echt, steht das da drin?
Ach, hier.
Die Polizei von San Francisco teilt jedoch später mit,
Unity habe einen eigenen Mitarbeiter als Urheber der Drohung angegeben.
Oh Mann.
Okay, der ist wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal arbeitslos.
Aber da sieht man, die sind auch ziemlich abgefuckt davon, so wie es aussieht.
Die Entscheidung scheint ja richtig Rückhalt zu haben in der Firma.
Verstehe ich nicht, wie man sowas nicht machen möchte.
Das wird...
Also wenn man das in Zukunft mal irgendwie für einen ordentlichen Preis noch weiter vermieten will,
dann muss das Ding Gigabit haben.
Ich verstehe nicht, wie die Leute...
Ich verstehe nicht, wie die Leute so pepega sein können.
Das ist wie mein Opa, ja.
Damals, als die die Straße aufgemacht haben, also damals ist schon wohl wirklich lange her,
um Kabel zu verlegen für Kabelfernsehen und später Internet und sowas, aber das war ja damals nicht,
hat mein Opa gesagt, nein, an mein Haus kommt nix dran.
Also alle beiden Nachbarn hatten das, aber mein Opa hat gesagt, nein, bei mir wird nichts angeschlossen.
Ich habe doch meine Antenne auf dem Dach.
Und er hat dann, der hat dann richtig Probleme später mit meinem Fang gehabt und alles.
Wollte er noch eine Satellitenschüssel und das war auch Mist wegen der Posi und so.
Das war eines der ersten Sachen, die wir damals gemacht haben, hier 2013 in dem Haus.
Noch einen Anschluss für Kabel.
Nicht unbedingt nur für Fernsehen, weil mich persönlich interessiert Fernsehen halt gar nicht,
sondern auch die Option zu haben,
anderen Internetprovider zu nehmen als irgendwas auf...
Kopfer-DSL-Telekom-based.
Weil da war ja damals schon abzusehen, dass mit 250 Mbit Super-V-Vectoring, wie auch immer das gen...
Wie heißt denn das eigentlich richtig? Super, Super?
Ich glaube einfach nur Super-Vectoring, ne?
Dass damit Schluss ist, mit dem ganzen DSL-Schrott.
Wir hatten es, wir hatten es lang genug.
P-P-P-O-E.
Da hat er wieder einen neuen Kubernetes-Cluster daheim.
Der braucht noch fünf weitere.
Was verdient...
Was verdient ein Landwirt? Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich glaube, das hat eine richtig große Range.
Es gibt welche, die das sehr Business-orientiert machen.
Und bestimmt auch welche, die das mehr so rein zur Liebe, zur Natur machen und
ich glaube, dementsprechend unterschiedlich wird da auch
das sein, was man da verdient.
Ende von Leder.
Okay, dann lass uns mal gucken, was man als Landwirt verdient.
Ich würde woanders mehr verdienen.
Wahrscheinlich auch.
Ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Muss sie laut?
Wie man jetzt gerade unschön sieht.
So soll das nicht sein.
Erst mal einen fetten Traktor anschmeißen.
Ich würde woanders mehr verdienen.
Wahrscheinlich auch.
Ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Wie man jetzt gerade unschön sieht.
So soll das nicht sein.
Ich habe für den Ausbau ein Gebiet aufgenommen.
6.000 Euro.
Wow.
Hi, ich bin Hans, bin 25 Jahre alt und arbeite als Landwirt auf unserem Familienbetrieb.
Zusammen mit meinem Vater.
Und das hier ist unser Hof.
5.15 Uhr. Alter, bin ich...
Ich bin, ich bin früher 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden und ich war eigentlich nicht überlebensfähig in der Zeit.
Ich habe mich von müde zu müde gehangelt.
Jetzt schnappen wir uns die Schaufel und machen die Liegeboxen sauber und treiben die Kühe alle zum Melkstand.
Lästertag wird es dann, wenn im Stall zum Beispiel eine Kuh krank wird, eigentlich passant.
Dann passiert fast jeden Tag irgendwas Unvorhersehbares.
Da ist ja auch viel.
Ja.
Mit 84? Mit 84 ist der Opa um 5 Uhr schon im Stall.
Na gut, das macht der wahrscheinlich sein Leben lang.
Aber der ist, der ist gut drauf.
Erst mal schon die Scheiße zusammenfegen.
Tschätke, Tschätke, Tschätke.
Was machst du morgens alles, dass du quasi eineinhalb Stunden oder so aufsteigst?
Stunden oder so aufstehen musst, bevor du aus dem Haus
gehst. Mein Opa ist auch
übelst früh aufgestanden, aber der ist danach
nicht in Stahlarbeit.
Kacken. Eineinhalb Stunden, ja gut, wenn's muss,
das muss, ja. Wo bloß gucken?
Ja, morgens um fünf, klar.
Also ich stehe um
ja, ziemlich genau um sieben
auf mittlerweile.
Nicht mal fünf auf 45 wie früher.
Sieben.
Und ich fang dann so um
acht Uhr
45 an.
Okay. Ich hab Panisch gelernt. Morgens.
Letztendlich muss jeder was finden, was für sich gut funktioniert.
Die Milch ist unser Hauptproduktionszweig.
Und damit
machen wir vorrangig unser Geld.
Wir liefern am Tag
ungefähr 1300 Liter
Milch ab. Boah.
Und das sind beim derzeitigen Milchpreis
von 35 Cent.
400 Euro circa am Tag.
Sozusagen Umsatz, kein Gewinn.
Los.
Die 36 ist ein Stinkstiefel,
die ärgert gerne mal die anderen Kühe.
Ja.
Und ist auch sehr träge.
Na los.
Langsam dick und ärgert die anderen Leute.
Hm.
Komm, hey.
Da erkennen sich manche bestimmt wieder.
Los, rein hier, komm.
Hopp.
Eine Bindung baut man schon auf, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wir jetzt im konkreten Fall
haben keinen Namen für jeden.
Es ist nur für jede einzelne Kuh.
Und natürlich
ist es nicht schön, wenn man dann eine Kuh
abgeben muss.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, sag ich mal,
wie bei einem Haustier, dass dann
drei Tage Staatstrauer ist, wenn es
diese Kuh dann nicht mehr gibt.
So. Ah, okay.
Ich glaube, dann wirst du auch abgehärtet mit der Zeit, ja?
Jetzt sind wir schon
eigentlich fertig damit. Müssen wir bloß nochmal rübergehen.
Jetzt hat gerade schon wieder eine Kuh dort reingekotet.
Gekotet?
Sprich CUD.
Genau. Danach, dann
haben die Kühe wieder alle ein frisches Bett.
Normalerweise sagt der doch
bestimmt auch, oh, guck mal, da hat schon wieder eine hingekackt.
Man achtet immer drauf. Das war jetzt die
gewählte Ausdrucksweise,
während das Fernsehteam da ist.
Das Kalb auch
richtig säuft, ob alles aussäuft.
Wenn es nicht säuft, dann merkt
man schon, aha, wird das Tier krank.
Natürlich muss man dann schnell handeln.
Komm.
Ich sauf jetzt auch was.
Komm, wollt ihr nicht?
Wie man jetzt gerade unschön sieht, so soll
das nicht sein. Eigentlich müssen die Kälber
sofort rangehen und saufen.
Aber so wie es aussieht, wollen die
gar nichts hier. Na, was ist denn los
mit euch? Aber ich sehe gerade auch, das hat
ein bisschen Durchfall. Also es kann sein, dass sie
wirklich gar nichts wollen.
Also entweder
heute Mittag dann nochmal schauen, ob sie dann saufen.
Und wenn nicht, dann müssen wir dann vielleicht
mal Fieber messen, ob sie krank werden.
Kommt da ein anderer, oder?
Kommt da ein anderer im September?
Wir haben ja einen kleinen Familienbetrieb, sage ich mal,
mein Vater und ich,
mit Tieren. Da würde ich durchdrehen,
wenn ich den ganzen Tag mit meinen Eltern hier irgendwie
zusammen hocke, arbeiten müsste.
Da würde ich durchdrehen, ja.
Mit unseren Milchkühen, und man ist zu zweit, und da hat man
wirklich jeden Tag Arbeit.
Auch zu Weihnachten, auch zum
Geburtstag, zu Ostern. Immer, ja.
Ja gut, das ist der Kuh ja egal.
Die scheißt auch am Feiertag.
Leute, die bei schönem Wetter an den
Badesee fahren und so, und man kann nicht mit, weil man
noch Arbeit zu erledigen hat.
Das sind dann die Schattenseiten.
Hier sind so die Kleinen.
Oh.
Wuppet.
Und wo ist die Mama?
Traktorfahren ist eigentlich
mit die schönste Arbeit
am ganzen Beruf, sage ich mal.
Aber es ist natürlich nicht nur Traktorfahren.
Ich sage mal, von meiner Zeit so sind
vielleicht 10% von Arbeitszeit
eine Traktorfahrzeit.
Aber natürlich ist es immer,
immer schön.
Traktorfahren ist porke.
Also mein Ziel ist, das Feld heute
PS.
Auch richtig outdated, overrated,
jebaited unit.
... zu schaffen, sind 18 Hektar.
Also 5, 6 Stunden am Ende
müsste alles fertig sein.
Landwirtschaft ist ja generell auch ein
gefährlicher Beruf.
Es gibt schon tödliche Verletzungen
oder tödliche Unfälle.
Das kommt nicht so selten
vor mit den großen Maschinen.
Wenn man da in
eine Maschine reinkommt, da sind so
viele Leistungen, die hält er
nicht an.
Weil letztens, ich habe letztens bei mir im Garten
den einen
Baumstumpf entfernen lassen.
Und
der Typ, der das gemacht hat, der hatte auch
einen Finger weniger. Auch gemeint, hat man
nicht aufgepasst.
Maschine, schnipp, schnapp.
Finger ab.
Wir haben jetzt noch ungefähr
7 Hektar. 6, 7 Hektar.
Das sollte man schaffen dann.
Jetzt gibt's Mittagessen.
Das ist indisches Chicken-Curry-Zeug, oder?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Ich meine, es können auch einfach
Hähnchen mit Rabensauce sein.
Das ist eher der Fall.
Jetzt müssen wir auf jeden Fall zu den
zwei Kleinkälbern nochmal genau gucken,
ob die jetzt saufen.
Das schlechteste, worst case wäre, wenn
sie eine Lungenentzündung bekommen.
Oder wenn sie krank werden.
Jetzt wird es gesackt.
Es tut auch ein bisschen
hecheln. Also denke ich mal, könnte es doch
anfangen werden, krank zu werden.
Ich hole gleich mal das Fieberthermometer.
Schauen wir mal, was es sagt.
Das ist ein normales Fieberthermometer, ja.
Warum sollte es
da nicht auch gehen?
Das sind jetzt 39 Grad Celsius.
Ist also schon leicht erhöht.
Wenn es nicht runter geht,
dann müssen wir mal einen Tierarzt holen.
Der muss das mal abhorchen.
Damit er dann ein Medikament
bekommen muss.
Ich musste mal, wo wir gerade beim Fiebermessen sind,
ich musste meiner
vorletzten Katze auch mal Fieber messen.
Ich habe gedacht,
Wunder, das wird
nichts.
Das klappt im Leben nicht.
Der Tierarzt hat gemeint,
messen sie doch mal Fieber.
Wie jetzt Fieber messen?
Einfach mit dem Fieberthermometer.
Und das ging tatsächlich ganz gut.
Ich habe die bei mir auf den Schoß gesetzt.
Ein bisschen festgehalten.
Und Fieberthermometer in Bobbes
Stückchen gemessen.
Gut, aber Katzen haben ja standardmäßig
eh ein bisschen höhere Temperatur.
Hat funktioniert.
Es war viel einfacher als gedacht.
Ich müsste das nicht jetzt
freiwillig, ich müsste das nicht jeden Tag machen.
Das war für alle Beteiligten unangenehm.
Aber das geht.
Nee, das hat ihr nicht gefallen.
Die hat
da gesessen. Ganz normal.
Auf dem Schoß hat sich nichts gedacht bei.
Und als
ich dann das Fieberthermometer in Bobbes
gesteckt habe,
hast du so richtig gemerkt so
Was ist das?
Also das geht ja schnell.
Das misst ja, 20 Sekunden ist das fertig.
Also hast du richtig der Katze angemerkt.
Was ist jetzt los?
Und als ich dann fertig war,
ist sie auch runter gehüpft und erst mal einen Schritt weg.
Was ist das hier? Geh mir bloß weg.
Aber die hat nichts gemacht.
Hat das über sich ergehen lassen.
So, fertig geworden.
Alles geklappt so wie es sollte.
Perfekt. Und dann geht es wieder weiter in den Stall.
Guck, der Unterschied ist
zwischen ihm und dieser
Excel
Schubser
Projektmanagerin, die sie da auch mal hatten.
Die habe ich mir gemerkt,
weil das so komplett entgegen dem war,
was ich mir so unter Arbeiten vorstelle.
Ist halt mal ein riesen Unterschied.
Der steht einfach 5 Uhr auf
und arbeitet bis, keine Ahnung, 18 Uhr oder so.
Und die andere telefoniert
dreimal am Tag und erstellt zwei Excel-Tabellen.
Geht vor, los.
Wie ist das
mit der Excel-Frau?
Irgendwas mit Beraterin
oder sowas.
Schauen wir mal nach Excel.
Ne.
Projekt?
Ja, wie hieß denn das?
Ja, die hier.
Sales Training.
Skills zum Vertriebs-
Selbstständig als Vertriebs-Trainerin.
Genau.
Die am Tag irgendwie zweimal telefoniert hat
und dreimal telefoniert hat und zwei Excel-Tabellen
erstellt hat.
Ich verdiene brutto
1690 Euro.
Oh, das ist ja bitter.
Das ist ja nix.
Und dafür bist du den ganzen Tag am schaffen.
Das ist ja echt wenig.
Also das zu
mindestens zwei vorne stehen,
2690,
aber das ist wirklich wenig.
Für die Arbeit, die das macht.
Und netto sind dann raus
1439.
Noch.
Das ist wirklich nicht viel.
Relativ viel netto übrig,
da ich ein
mitarbeitendes Familienmitglied bin.
Ja, zum Glück muss er davon nicht so viele Steuern bezahlen.
Trotzdem,
1400 Euro netto ist echt nicht
nicht so
toll.
Und sozusagen die
Krankenbeiträge und
Pflegebeiträge von
meinem Vater vom Betrieb
zu 100 Prozent abgehen.
Okay, das ist natürlich ganz gut.
Ich bekomme 500 Euro Weihnachtsgeld.
Da kommt man dann schlussendlich
auf ein Jahresbrutto von
20.780.
Ich mein Mindestlohn ist, glaub ich,
irgendwie 1.100 Euro oder sowas im Monat.
Da ist das schon mehr.
Aber trotzdem,
es ist wirklich wenig.
Es ist echt wenig.
Ich würde woanders mehr verdienen.
Ordentlich mehr.
Wahrscheinlich auch ein ganzes Stück
mehr.
Aber woanders würde ich
wahrscheinlich keinen Betrieb übernehmen können.
Na gut.
Na gut, okay.
Ist halt die Frage, ob man das so rechnen kann.
Wenn ich mir das recht überlege.
Ich mein,
das, was er quasi als Monatsgehalt kriegt,
aber nachdem das ein Familienbetrieb ist,
geht ja irgendwie das,
was er dort verdient,
also was die Firma verdient,
am Jahresende,
zwar nicht direkt in seine
Tasche, aber potenziell
in seine Tasche noch.
Es ist insgesamt schon echt nicht viel.
Vielleicht scammt ihn der Vater.
Man weiß nicht.
Würde ich jetzt aber mal nicht von ausgehen.
Kommt mal her.
Gutes Zeichen, dass es gleich aufsteht.
Jetzt hat es Hunger.
Drum, drum, drum, drum.
Jawoll.
Moment.
Kann das trinken und muhen gleichzeitig?
Hab ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Multitasking-Kalb.
Guck mal, das trinkt.
Oder das andere muht.
Und das ist deine.
Perfekt.
So soll es sein.
Da
stinkt es bestimmt auch übelst.
Ich
laufe manchmal vorbei an so einem,
ja auch so einem
Betrieb, sowas in der Richtung.
Die haben auch Schweine,
Kühe, Schafe und so.
Und da läufst du manchmal vorbei
und je nach Tag
liegt da halt eins bis drei
riesengroße Misthaufen.
Und wenn du da vorbeiläufst, Alter, boah.
Da bin ich immer doppelt so schnell,
wie sonst. Da stinkt es immer.
Oh Mann.
Und je nach Wind kriegst du das
quasi schon die halbe Strecke ab.
Ich wohne sozusagen im Dachgeschoss
in unserem Haus und bin erst vor kurzem
sogar fertig geworden mit dem Ausbauen.
Also ganz frisch.
Also ich hab...
Warst du nie in den Bergen wandern?
Also das, was Schweizer und Österreicher
unter Bergen verstehen?
Ausbauen, Kredit aufgenommen, 6000 Euro.
Und die zahle ich jetzt monatlich über zwei Jahre ab.
Das höchste bei uns ist 450 Meter.
Genau.
Mein Hobby ist das Enduro
und Motocross fahren.
Und es ist schon sehr, sehr teuer.
5.500 Euro hab ich damals bezahlt.
2017.
Das kannst du ja sogar fast schon für ein Fahrrad ausgeben heute.
Ich hab's mal zusammengerechnet, glaub
8.000 bis 9.000 Euro reingesteckt.
An Ersatzteile, Reparaturen.
Pipapo.
War vielleicht nicht die vernünftigste Investition,
aber eine gute.
Jetzt kann er
über den eigenen Acker heizen damit.
Eigentlich auch nice.
Bisschen angegeben
mit dem Wheelie.
Für mich lohnt sich's auf jeden Fall.
Es ist einfach der schönste Beruf, den man sich vorstellen kann.
Und ich mach ihn jeden Tag gerne.
Oh nein! Nein, nein, nein!
Toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast, toast.
Oh.
Ich mein er schwimmt nicht im Geld,
aber letztendlich ist es auch egal,
solange er happy ist.
Dann könnt ihr das doch auch tun.
Und hier kommt er noch zu weiteren Videos
zum Beispiel zum Metzgermeister
oder zu anderen Videos.
Metzgermeister, den haben wir auch noch nicht geguckt.
Gucken wir jetzt auch nicht.
Was anderes...
Welches davon?
mein Kumpel macht seinen Landwirtbetrieb dicht
und macht damit einfach keine Kohle mehr.
Ich stell's mir schwierig vor in Deutschland.
Sowas,
sagen wir mal, langfristig
irgendwie vertretbar und ordentlich
Kohle zu betreiben.
Ja, das sieht er
bestimmt anders. Also,
für mich wär das auch nix. Für mich wär das viel zu viel
Natur und Stinkezeug
und alles.
Aber,
die Leute sind halt unterschiedlich.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass wir
in absehbarer Zeit keine Kumpel
mehr brauchen.
Natur ist richtig Dancegame.
Einzige Mal Natur ist ganz
gut, wenn ich irgendwie mal ein bisschen rumlaufen will draußen.
So, was haben wir denn
sonst noch hier?
Was ist das denn für eine Playlist? Das ist
Beachside Holiday
Nintendo Summer Music Mix.
Was haben wir denn hier?
WhatsApp?
Oh, ist das...
Ist das
diesmal ein anderer?
Ist das nicht der
liebe Hackerinnen und Hacker?
WhatsApp wird
für Telegram, Signal und Co. geöffnet.
Aha.
Na, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie Lukas was macht.
Guck mal hier.
Das bin ich, wie ich versuche, mit Signal
Leuten auf WhatsApp zu schreiben.
Und Überraschung, klappt nicht. Könnte es
aber, wenn es nach der EU geht.
Ach so, die wollen
sie da... Na, ob das was wird?
Und ihr denkt euch jetzt bestimmt,
ja, cool, aber wo ist Kino?
Ja, der ist leider krank und deswegen übernehme
ich die Woche 2003. Also,
schau mal hier. Das ist der Digital Markets
Act der EU. Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
boah, hören wir mit dem langweiligen Scheiß
auf. Ja, gut, dann sind wir eigentlich
einer Meinung. Das ist nämlich wirklich
alles andere als spannend, so 100
Seiten Gesetzestext durchzulesen.
Haben wir aber trotzdem mal gemacht. Warum?
Wetten, dass selbst die Leute, die
darüber abstimmen, die 100 Seiten
nicht gelesen haben, nicht mal Ansatzweise.
Die haben irgendeinen Dude, der das
für die zusammengefasst hat. Je nachdem, wie gut er
das gemacht hat. Wissen sie Bescheid oder nicht?
Weil die EU da ganz schön viele
Dinge regelt, die unseren digitalen
Alltag krass verändern könnten.
Das neue iPhone zum Beispiel hat jetzt
unter anderem wegen der EU USB-C.
Also, wie jedes anderes.
Aber war das nicht so mit
Kack-Datenübertragung mit USB-C?
Apple muss auf seinen iPhones
Zeitloading, also das Installieren von
Apps außerhalb des App-Stores erlauben
und WhatsApp. Moment, Moment.
Das geht doch die ganze Zeit.
Die Zeit schon.
Zeitloading? Aber das Problem ist,
dass diese Apps sich nach sieben Tagen
oder so automatisch wieder aninstallen.
Das haben, also wenn die das
anpassen, wäre extremely
nice.
Das wäre richtig gut.
Aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
wird das wieder irgendeinen Haken haben bei Apple.
Installieren von
Apps außerhalb des App-Stores erlauben
und WhatsApp muss bald mit allen
Messengern kompatibel werden. Denn
wenn es nach der EU geht, dann müssen bald
alle großen Messenger-Anbieter miteinander
funktionieren. Interoperabilität
heißt das. Warum das jetzt vielleicht
Das wird wahrscheinlich
so pepeger umgesetzt,
dass es am Ende keiner benutzen will.
So nach dem Motto
Plaintext only
140 Zeichen
und unverschlüsselt, so nach dem Motto.
Vielleicht besser klingt,
als es dann wirklich ist. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei
Keine Sonderzeit.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Yonos. Seit über 25 Jahren
ist Yonos im Hosting-Geschäft unterwegs
und der bürgerdeutsche Digitalisierungspartner.
Zehn Rechenzentren in
fünf Ländern mit 100.000 Servern hat
Chat. Was ist
mit euch los?
Da hat jemand beim USB-Standard
nicht aufgepasst. Was soll das?
Das ist nicht USB 3.0.
Das ist USB
4.0 Gen
3.2
3x1 X4
oder sowas.
Wie kannst du sagen, es ist USB 3.0?
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich schicke es direkt an das USB-Konsortium.
Gremium.
Und dann darfst du nie wieder im Leben USB verwenden.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben.
Also, um ganz korrekt zu sein, heißt das jetzt.
Moment.
Um ganz, ganz korrekt zu sein, heißt das jetzt.
Äh.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht.
Äh.
Heißt das jetzt?
Ich blicke entweder in der Tabelle nicht durch.
Ja, das ist gut.
USB 3.0 Gen 1x1
Heißt es jetzt, okay?
Bitteschön.
Und es wird noch viel geiler,
wenn es das ganze USB 4.0 V2
gibt!
WPD Translatoride
Das ist so dämlich.
Ich meine,
warum nicht 4.0 und 4.1,
please?
Und dann gibt es
USB 4.2.0
und es gibt auch noch USB 2.0.
Das ist so dämlich, Alter.
Ich kann es mir auch
nicht anders vorstellen, als dass das Absicht ist.
Da klingt einfach
USB 3.2 neuer als USB 4.
Also die korrekte
Bezeichnung heutzutage wäre, um das jetzt
nochmal abzuschließen,
die korrekte Bezeichnung wäre
heutzutage USB 3.2 Gen 1x1.
Oder alternativ
Superspeed USB.
Die auch noch ist im Einsatz.
Und da findet ihr ziemlich sicher genau das, was ihr braucht.
Zum Beispiel in Sachen VPS.
Natürlich auch mit ordentlich GPU-Power.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Fallen wir mal auf die Werbung rein.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Was?
Achtung, Flashbang.
Boah, mein Auge.
Was kostet hier?
Domain, Hosting, WordPress, Cloud Computing.
Products.
Compute Engine.
Wisst ihr, eine Zeit lang hieß das einfach mal VM.
Aber Compute Engine klingt natürlich einfach
viel geiler.
View Prices.
Gibt es sowas wie
Shared Core oder so?
Okay, wir kriegen...
Hä?
Kann ich nicht einfach mal was anklicken?
Ich nehme mal eine ordentliche Tabelle.
Was, was kostet jetzt?
Okay.
Ähm, hier.
Also.
Zwei CPUs.
8G RAM.
Und ein bisschen SSD wahrscheinlich.
Kostet.
Ähm.
11, 11 Cent.
Oder 12 Cent die Stunde.
Also mal 24.
Am Tag.
Ähm, mal, ja, keine Ahnung.
30.
What?
Das ist übelst.
Ultra.
Habe ich mich verrechnet?
Habe ich mich irgendwie verrechnet?
Das ist abfuck.
Megast teuer.
Muss man vielleicht ein Komma dazwischen machen?
Mal 24?
Nee.
Also es kostet ungefähr 3 Euro am Tag.
Boah, das ist...
Das ist ULTRA teuer.
Alter, was sind das für Preise?
Ich meine, vergleichen wir das mal beispielsweise.
Das kostet, das kostet ja bei Google weniger.
Da, ich habe doch jetzt irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Mach mal mal 720 für den Monat.
Du meinst das hier?
Ja, ist genau das gleiche.
Ja.
Ich meine...
Habe ich vielleicht das falsche Produkt mir angeguckt?
Ja.
Weil ich meine, guck mal.
Bei Hetzner kriegst du eine kleine Kiste, ähnliche Ausstattung für 14 Euro im Monat.
Und das ist auch ganz schön teuer geworden, ne?
Animon, das ist dedicated.
Okay, ja.
Aber ich wollte gerade sagen, ne?
Also, da kriegst du teilweise Sachen für unter 10 Euro.
Also, das ist teuer.
Bin ich verkehrt?
Iona Server, bin ich verkehrt?
Ist das, ist Compute Engine kein, keine VM?
Hm.
Ach hier, Servers gibt's auch noch.
Und dann, und dann haben wir noch...
Dann haben sie auch noch Cloud-Servers.
Okay, das ist wieder so undurchsichtiges, undurchsichtiges Ding.
Choose Data Center, Frankfurt.
Ja, das sind, das sind doch schon angenehmere Preise.
Damit, damit kann man doch leben.
Das ist doch okay.
4 CPUs, 8G, 240G, SSD.
Ich hoffe, es ist SSD, ja.
Aber, aber, kostet später 50.
Also, das sind Preise, die sind okay.
Aber, jetzt mal, also, was ist der Vorteil jetzt von der Compute Instance?
Ist das Shared, ist das Shared CPU oder wie?
Oder, ich, ich verstehe so nicht den Unterschied, warum ich das andere kaufen sollte.
Na gut.
Wie auch immer, irgendein, MonkaS, ja, ja.
Irgendeinen Sinn wird's schon haben.
Und wenn's ein Unsinn ist, hätte man auch einen.
Das hat mein Opa jetzt gesagt.
Das war so ein Cringe-Spruch von ihm.
Den hat er laufend gebracht, wenn irgendwas war, was ihm nicht gefällt.
Aber er keinen Bock hatte zu begründen, was ihm nicht gefällt.
Ja, das ist, das, das ist Ultra-Boomer.
Aber ich meine, das war mein Opa.
Also, mein Opa war noch Pre-Boomer.
Der, der, das, die gab's noch gar nicht.
Mein Opa hat die Boomer-Generation auf die, mit auf die Welt gebracht, so.
Sind von dir stehen geblieben, ne?
Der malende Opa, ja.
Ich hab nur einen Opa.
Also, ich hab theoretisch natürlich auch einen zweiten Opa,
aber ich glaube, den kenn ich nicht.
Vielleicht waren wir da irgendwann mal, wo ich klein war, keine Ahnung.
Ich kenn, ich kenn nur eine Oma und nur einen Opa.
Gar nicht, erst mal.
Wir haben nichts, nichts mehr abgesprochen in letzter Zeit.
Ich mach auch grad ein bisschen wenig Gestrimse und so.
Das passt grad nicht.
Denkst du eine Ausbildung zum Fisi bei einem großen Telekommunikationsunternehmen,
welches ein magenter Hintergrund auf dem Logo hat, ist eine gute Entscheidung?
Ja, denke ich.
Nee, Offline-Events, kein Bock.
IONOS, Terraform, ja.
Die haben einen eigenen Terraform-Provider.
Es hat so ziemlich jeder Cloud-Anbieter, der was auf sich hält, einen eigenen Terraform-Anbieter.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel KI-Anwendungen machen wollt.
Und einen Cloud-Anbieter, der keinen Terraform-Provider hat, den kannst du halt nicht benutzen.
Deswegen gibt's die halt auch immer weniger.
Bei IONOS, ihr bekommt 24-7 echten technischen Support mit dedizierten Ansprechpartnern.
Echten? Guck mal, da ruft dich dann Dr. Best an oder sowas.
Ja.
Der Messenger-Markt ist also an dem Punkt angekommen, wo sich die Politik gezwungen sieht einzugreifen.
Schon krass.
Denn früher war das eigentlich schon mal besser gelöst.
Ganz oldschool kann man da seit fast 30 Jahren jeden mit einem Handy erreichen.
Ein Nokia-Communicator.
Sowas hatte ich damals.
Damals habe ich beim Provider-Garantor.
habe auch bekommen das war noch pre iphone hat ein nokia communicator zwar richtig räudig das
ding dritten dezember 1992 hat der ingenieur neil pepworth die allererste sms der welt verschickt
kurz und knapp hat er darin einem kollegen merry christmas gewünscht ja und dann ging es so richtig
los die sms wurde der verkaufsschlager der mobilfunkanbieter bis zu 39 cent haben kunden
früher für eine sms mit 140 sms in heute immer noch übelst teuer bezahlen müssen so richtig und
allein nicht teuer wurden alleine in deutschland noch über 59 milliarden sms verschickt der erfolg
der sms kam wie bei der e mail auch weil es einen einheitlichen standard gibt den jeder benutzt jeder
kann ein dass ständigen erreichen egal ob sony ericsson aber leute leute leute ernsthaft wenn
telegramm und signal und so und whatsapp miteinander reden können ein message fällt
doch nicht auf die hände der menschen und die menschen und die menschen und die menschen und
menschen und die menschen und die menschen und die menschen und die menschen und die menschen und
doch bestimmt wieder raus oder ein message wird doch apple macht doch bestimmt nicht mit
rola lg oder nokia handy man musste sich also keine gedanken machen welche plattform der
andere benutzt ja und diesen kostenpflichtigen luxus den haben uns die ganzen messaging anbieter
dann wieder genommen weil heute viele auf whatsapp schreiben andere auf signal manche
auf telegramm und dann gibt es noch streamer oder ein message you name it also es gibt
messenger anbieter wie sand am meer und die sind fast alle gratis
und können auch mehr als diese old school sms aber das hat einen entscheidenden nachteil wenn
ich mit jemandem schreiben möchte der nicht gleich wie ich habe dann sms von uns beiden halt wohl oder
übel einen neuen messenger oder sms das ist natürlich mega nervig und kundenunfreundlich
für uns verbraucher und deswegen möchte die eu jetzt große anbieter dazu zwingen dass sie
miteinander funktionieren und deswegen gilt seit mai 2023 der digital markets act also das gesetz
über digitale märkte und das besonders bei den digitales marken weil das betrifft die diesen
mobilen und digitalen marken und durch diesem gesetz wird die digitalen marken bzw die digitalen
marken oder die digitalen marken oder die digitalen marken oder die digitalen marken oder die digitalen marken
oder die digitalen marken und das besagte und das besagt dass die digitalen marken oder die digitalen marken
Und das besagt, große Anbieter, also sogenannte Gatekeeper, müssen ihre Angebote für andere Anbieter auf deren Verlangen zugänglich machen.
Oder einfach gesagt, WhatsApp muss es zum Beispiel Wire ermöglichen, Nachrichten mit WhatsApp auszutauschen.
Als solche Gatekeeper zählen für die EU Anbieter, die zum einen mehr als 45 Millionen monatlich akzeptieren.
Ich finde es vom Ansatz her eigentlich nicht schlecht.
... die wir Nutzer in der EU haben, die in mehr als drei EU-Ländern ihre Dienste anbieten und die in den letzten drei Jahren mindestens 7,5 Milliarden Euro Umsatz erzielt haben.
Du bist wer? Danke für den Sub.
Die EU hat jetzt offiziell mitgeteilt, welche Anbieter unter diese Regelung fallen werden.
Das sind Alphabet, also Google, Amazon, Apple, ByteDance, also TikTok.
Okay, Apple bedeutet auch iMessage.
... und Microsoft.
Für das Messaging bedeutet das aber, dass nur Meta, also WhatsApp und der Facebook Messenger unter diese Regelung fallen.
iMessage wird zwar gerade noch geprüft, aber laut Apple hat der Dienst weniger als 45 Millionen monatlich aktive Nutzer in der EU und würde deswegen gar nicht unter diese Regelung fallen.
Oh nee!
Ja, und jetzt hat Meta eben sechs Monate Zeit, diese Regelungen umzusetzen und die beiden Dienste auf das Verlangen von anderen Anbietern hin zu öffnen.
Erstmal nur für Einzelchats, innerhalb von zwei Jahren dann auch für Gruppenchats und nochmal später dann auch für Videoanrufe und ganz normale Anrufe.
... und ganz normale Anrufe.
Und dann sind schon Screenshots von dem WhatsApp-Update rumgegangen, die ein Chatfenster für Drittanbieter-Chats zeigen.
Okay.
Ja, und heißt das jetzt, der Lukas vom Anfang aus diesem Video kann dann einfach mit Signal all seine Kontakte erreichen?
Nein.
Denn auch wenn Meta jetzt von der EU gezwungen wird, ihre Dienste zu öffnen, die kleinen Anbieter müssen da halt auch mitmachen wollen.
Und ich sag mal so, wenn ich jetzt als Nutzer zu einem kleineren Anbieter wie Threema gehen würde, damit meine Daten gerade nicht bei Meta landen,
dann fände ich es nicht so nice, wenn die auf einmal eine Schnittstelle zu Meta...
... also zu WhatsApp oder dem Facebook-Messenger anbieten würden.
Signal hat deswegen auch schon länger angekündigt, dass sie bei dieser ganzen Interoperabilität nicht mitmachen wollen.
Und weil Signal eben kein Gatekeeper ist, kann sie die EU auch nicht dazu zwingen.
Genauso wie Threema übrigens, die auch schon angekündigt haben, dass sie sich bei diesem Thema erstmal zurückhalten.
Verständlich, ja.
Das Problem ist, neben der Sorge um die Nutzerdaten, die dann bei Meta landen, auch, dass dann genau das Gegenteil passieren könnte.
Also kleinere Anbieter befürchten, dass am Ende eher weniger Nutzer auf ihre Plattformen...
... kommen, wenn die auch von WhatsApp aus erreichbar wären.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Es könnte, Stand jetzt, also tatsächlich passieren, dass Facebook-Messenger und WhatsApp Drittanbieter-Chats zwar ermöglichen,
das aber niemand in Anspruch nimmt.
Was aber wirklich nochmal Bewegung in dieses Interoperabilitätsthema bringen könnte,
wäre, wenn die EU iMessage zu einem Gatekeeper erklären würde.
Sollte Apple iMessage öffnen müssen, wäre das nämlich tatsächlich eine krasse Veränderung.
In den USA sind iPhones deutlich verbreiteter als hier bei uns.
Und damit...
... ist iMessage weltweit einer der beliebtesten Messaging-Anbieter, der aber nur auf iPhones funktioniert.
Kontakte ohne iPhone bekommen dann einfach eine normale SMS zugeschickt.
Und der Chat hat dann eine grüne statt einer blauen Sprechblase.
Ja.
Was bedeutet, diese Textnachricht war jetzt vielleicht kostenpflichtig.
Auf jeden Fall nicht kostenlos über das Internet übertragen, sondern ganz oldschool eine SMS.
Und damit hält Apple auch wirklich Leute bei iMessage und dem iPhone, weil sie ihre Blue Bubbles nicht verlieren wollen.
Und in Deutschland könnten...
... iPhone-Nutzer dann einfach aus der Nachrichten-App heraus mit WhatsApp-Kontakten chatten.
Das wäre cool.
Und eben andersrum.
Und sollte iMessage wirklich als Gatekeeper benannt werden, dann müssten sie auch mitmachen.
Die Strafen, wenn sich Unternehmen nicht daran halten, sind nämlich super hoch.
Bis zu 10% vom weltweiten Gesamtumsatz und bei wiederholter Zuwiderhandlung sogar bis zu 20%.
Technisch wird die Interoperabilität wohl über ein neues gemeinsames Protokoll umgesetzt, das auch verschlüsselt.
Denn bisher verwenden Messenger wie WhatsApp...
... teilweise unterschiedliche Protokolle, die sie selbst entwickelt haben.
Das ist natürlich heftig, ja.
Was magst du von Serenity als das Community-Roundtable ansehen?
Nee, heute nicht.
Wahrscheinlich...
Nee, nee, nee.
... nicht mit anderen kompatibel sind.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch einer der größten Knackpunkte an der ganzen Geschichte.
Weil das Zusammenführen von Konversationen zwischen verschiedenen Anbietern nicht einfach mit dem Umlegen von dem Hebel funktioniert.
Es braucht also eine Möglichkeit, um zwischen den verschiedenen Messengern die Interoperabilität anbieten,
zu vermitteln.
Eine Lösung dafür könnte das Messaging Layer Security Protocol sein, kurz MLS.
Damit soll zukünftig sichere Kommunikation mit Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung auch in Gruppen möglich sein.
Meta hat bei der Entwicklung übrigens mitgewirkt, genauso wie Google, Mozilla oder AWS.
Damit gäbe es dann einen einheitlichen Standard zur Verschlüsselung...
Amazon!
... und der könnte auch von kleineren Anbietern...
Ist ja, AWS ist auch so ein dummes Wort, weil jeder auf der Welt spricht es sinnvoll aus, nur die Amis nicht.
... genutzt werden, wenn sie denn wohnen.
Was MLS aber wesentlich löst, ist die Frage, wie sich Nutzer in unterschiedlichen Plattformen denn eigentlich finden können.
Und was mit Nutzern ist, die ihre Nummer schon für unterschiedliche Dienste verwenden.
Könnten die dann einen Standarddienst zum Beispiel angeben.
Joa, ist noch ein bisschen was zu tun in den nächsten sechs Monaten, sage ich mal.
Mein Fazit.
Also in der Theorie ist das, was die EU davor hat, auf jeden Fall erstmal gut.
Denn große Monopole führen über einen längeren Zeitraum...
... bei den Usern eigentlich nie zu mehr Zufriedenheit.
Also, dass die EU jetzt zum Beispiel Apple vorschreibt, dass sie auf den iPhones auch Apps erlauben müssen, die nicht aus dem App Store kommen, richtig gut.
Aber ich wage mal zu bezweifeln, ob sich durch diese Änderungen bei den Messengern jetzt ernsthaft was verändert.
Weil die EU kann Meta noch so sehr zwingen, seine Pforten zu öffnen.
Wenn kein anderer Anbieter Bock hat, dann bleibt halt alles so, wie es ist.
Also, wenn man wirklich für jeden erreichbar sein möchte und auch jeden erreichen möchte, dann bleibt einem wahrscheinlich auch...
... in Zukunft nichts anderes übrig, als mehrere Messenger-Dienste auf seinem Smartphone zu installieren.
Das machen aber wieder nur wenige und so beißt sich die Katze dann irgendwie wieder in den Schwanz.
Und am Ende ist es dann einfach wieder das Leichteste, einfach auf WhatsApp zu sein, weil da sind im Zweifel halt alle.
Wie seht ihr das?
Nutzt ihr einen anderen Messenger als WhatsApp?
Und würdet ihr euch wünschen, damit auch an WhatsApp-Nutzer Nachrichten schreiben zu können?
Also, ich fänd's cool, von iMessage aus an WhatsApp zum Beispiel schreiben zu können.
Schreibt's gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Das wär nice, der Rest interessiert mich nicht.
Und dann könnt ihr mich natürlich auch gerne abonnieren. Tschüss!
Tschüss!
Wäre nice. Also wenn... ups.
Wenn das funktionieren würde, wäre wirklich extrem... extremely... hog.
Oder was denkt ihr? Also, iMessage fänd ich nice, der Rest interessiert mich jetzt persönlich nicht so.
Ich mein, es gab ja früher schon mal sowas ähnliches. Es gab ja früher Multi-Messenger, so Pidgin oder...
Was gab's denn da sonst noch? Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Kennt das noch irgendjemand?
Kennt noch jemand Pidgin? Messenger?
Kennst du die Videos Media vom... Ja, kenn ich.
Kennt das Ding noch jemand? Pidgin?
Konntest du ICQ mitmachen, Jabber, AOL und alles mögliche?
Und da gab es auch schon Verschlüsselungs-Plugins für, die auf Plaintext-Kommunikation aufgesetzt haben.
Da gab's dann zum Beispiel OTR.
Und das konntest du über... alle Messenger gleichermaßen machen, aber trotzdem verschlüsselt.
Der Messenger selbst hat dann, das war halt kleinseitig verschlüsselt, hat dann nur noch gesehen, dass halt verschlüsselt übertragen wurde.
Das war eigentlich ganz cool. Etwas outdated heutzutage, ja.
Wir sollten bald den Universal-Champ entwickeln, der kann einfach... der vereint alle Champs.
Der Meta-Champ.
Programmierer reagiert auf Zuschauer-Apps.
Wir könnten auf den Programmierer reagieren, der auf Zuschauer-Apps reagiert.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? 30...
Der Auer! Haben wir lange nichts mehr geguckt.
30 Jahre altes Tool soll CPUs vor Überhitzung schützen.
Okay, mal gucken.
Der Auer.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem weiteren Video.
Ich hab mal wieder was Verrücktes ausgegraben, und zwar das Systotec.
Und das ist ein Tool, das ist fast 30 Jahre alt, das schauen wir uns gleich natürlich noch genauer an.
Ist nicht so alt wie ich.
Und das sollte verhindern anscheinend, dass die CPU überhitzt.
Aber ich hab mir das angeschaut und hab da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, ob das Ding überhaupt funktionieren kann.
Das schauen wir uns im heutigen Video an.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Corsair mit dem neuen 2000D Mini-ITX-Gehäuse.
Ich hab selbst vor einigen Wochen eins...
Da muss ich echt sagen, das finde ich schick, das Case.
Also wenn man gern so ein Ding auf dem Schreibtisch stehen hat, sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Lautsprecher.
Findet ihr nicht auch? Sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein alter Lautsprecher.
Das System in dem Gehäuse, gebaut für Corsair Deutschland.
Und muss sagen, war sehr zufrieden mit den Montagemöglichkeiten von 360 AIO und auch langen Grafikkarten bis 365 mm.
Auch SFXL-Netzteile mit bis zu 1000 Watt lassen sich wirklich Probleme lösen.
Moment, das fängt doch total viel Staub, oder? Wenn es daneben offen ist.
Dieses kleine System verbauen.
Ich verlinke euch mal unten das Gehäuse und vor allem auch mein Video bei Corsair Deutschland.
Da könnt ihr euch einfach mal anschauen, wie ich dieses System gebaut habe.
Schaut euch das gerne nach diesem Video mal an.
So sieht das Gerät aus.
Sysotec CPU Fan Failure und Thermal Over 110°C Warning Device.
Und ich hab mir da so gedacht, so was zur Hölle soll das eigentlich sein?
Haha.
Auf den ersten Blick, hier oben kommt erstmal Strom.
Übertaktet das den Lüfter oder was?
Da steht Current Power und hier unten steht Current Fan Plug.
Also das soll dann...
Ist das ein Lüftungsübertakter?
Im Prinzip einfach nur zwischen die CPUs.
V486, DX, Pentium und Pentium Pro, ok.
Damals war halt, damals konntest du die CPU auch noch kühlen, indem du drauf gepustet hast.
Lüfter, Stromversorgung geschaltet werden.
Das heißt, wir sehen hier CPU und Fan.
Und da soll das einfach nur dazwischen.
Und dann soll das...
Dann soll das irgendwie, ich weiß nicht genau wie, uns davor bewahren, dass die CPU 110°C warm wird.
Wie man hier oben sehen kann.
Bei 110°C ist schon alles tot.
Also gerade die neue CPU-Generation, die hält erstaunlich viel aus.
Ich meine 110°C, wenn die sich wahrscheinlich auch schon lange runtergetaktet haben.
Aber 105°C machen die.
Kleines Detail, hier unten steht V486, DX, Pentium und Pentium Pro Systems.
Wenn wir uns einfach nur die CPUs anschauen.
Also V486, DX, den gab es ja von AMD und auch Intel.
Dann Intel Pentium und Pentium Pro.
Die CPUs sind von dem Zeitraum von 1994, 1995.
Das heißt, das Ding hier ist wahrscheinlich um die 28 Jahre alt.
Das hat also ein paar Jährchen auf dem Buckel.
Ist auf jeden Fall cool, dass es noch neu und original verpackt ist.
Wenn man sich allerdings zum Beispiel so ein V486 hier anschaut.
Oder auch den Pentium oder Pentium Pro.
Dann wird man feststellen, dass diese CPUs nicht über 85°C laufen können.
Und wenn man dann sieht, dass das die CPU vor 110°C beschützen soll.
Dann bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie zur Hölle das eigentlich funktionieren soll.
Das werden wir dann vielleicht gleich rausfinden, wenn wir uns das Ding im Detail anschauen.
Ansonsten seht ihr hier hinten, PE Logic ist der Hersteller.
Die bewerben hier alles mögliche mit Connections.
Was soll ich machen, wenn mein Laptop hängt und so Geräusche macht und ich nicht drücken oder mit der Tasche.
Wenn der Laptop Geräusche macht.
Das kann ja meistens nur an irgendeinem Lüfter liegen.
Da wirst du wahrscheinlich aufschrauben müssen.
Du könntest auch mal versuchen durchzupusten mit so einer Druckluftflasche.
So einem Druckluftspray, wenn du sowas hast.
Aber wahrscheinlich wirst du den aufmachen müssen.
Zu SCSI aka SCSI.
Das heißt, das ist dieser alte lange Anschluss.
Den kennen vielleicht die einen oder anderen von euch noch.
Den man mal früher an dem PC hatte.
Und dann bin ich auf die Webseite von PE Logic gegangen.
Beziehungsweise ich wollte.
Musste feststellen, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Welche Überraschung.
Habe dann die Wayback Machine verwendet.
Und habe dann gesehen, dass es PE Logic seit dem Jahr 2000 schon nicht mehr gibt.
Wirklich, wirklich lange.
Die haben also nicht lange überlebt.
Liegt vielleicht daran, weil dieses Produkt vielleicht gar keinen Sinn macht.
Was wir noch rausfinden müssen.
Ansonsten habe ich dann noch versucht den einen oder anderen Snapshot von Wayback Machine von dieser Firma hier zu öffnen.
Und musste dann feststellen, dass man zu diesem Teil hier einfach nichts findet.
Also wirklich rein gar nichts.
Das heißt, ich habe keinerlei Ahnung, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Wie zur Hölle dieses Ding feststellen möchte, ob die CPU 110 Grad Celsius warm wurde.
Auf der Verpackung haben wir noch den einen oder anderen Hinweis.
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher, wie das funktionieren soll.
Denn hier steht zum Beispiel, emits a piercing sound when CPU fan fails or system overheats.
Das heißt, hier steht dran, dass dieses Teil.
Das müsst ihr aber irgendwie erstmal messen können, wie warm die CPU überhaupt ist.
Es hat überhaupt keine Probe oder so dran.
Wenn ein schönes Geräusch erzeugen soll.
Wenn der CPU Lüfter nicht mehr funktioniert oder das System überhitzt.
Wie genau das funktionieren soll, dass der merkt, dass die CPU überhitzt, ist mir einfach nicht ganz klar.
Ja, mir auch nicht.
Irgendeine Kommunikation mit der CPU stattfinden.
Aber vielleicht ist da irgendwas dran, was ich noch nicht verstanden habe oder gesehen habe.
Ansonsten gibt es hier immer noch viel Werbung an der Seite, was alles passieren kann.
Schlimmes, wenn euer CPU Lüfter ausfällt bei den High Speed Computern.
Made in USA.
Coconut Time.
486.
Und was da alles passieren kann.
Und hier steht dann eben einfach, wenn der Lüfter ausfällt, dann hilft euch Systotec mit dem Ton.
Und dann soll man den Lüfter wechseln und dann hilft Systotec wieder, das System zu überwachen.
Wie genau, ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein absolutes Rätsel.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein Dongle, den man heute an den Bus da im Auto stecken kann.
Wie heißt der?
Also erstmal haben wir hier.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Es gibt ja für Autos so Sachen zum Auslesen.
Die sehen ein bisschen so ähnlich aus.
Ein Sticker unter dem Gerät und da steht dran, dass man diesen Sticker am Gehäuse, am System anbringen soll, dass wenn dieser Warnton ertönt, dann überhitzt das System auf jeden Fall und man muss irgendwie den Lüfter tauschen.
Okay.
Und hier haben wir unsere magische, ich will nicht sagen Black Box, weil es transparent.
Oh, guter Molex Stecker.
Nur ein Molex für Power und Molex raus für den Lüfter.
Hier hinten, da sollte der kleine Speaker sein.
Hier ist noch ein kleiner Ausschnitt drin.
Warum bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher?
Das könnte in Temperatur sein.
Wie ist erstmal ein CPU Lüfter heute über Molex an?
Ich schau mal, ob ich das öffnen kann.
Vielleicht werden wir da schlauer.
Ich werde da ehrlich gesagt auch nicht ganz schlau draus.
Also das in der Mitte ist auf jeden Fall ein Komparator.
Also der vergleicht einfach zwei Spannungen.
Kann vielleicht die Eingangsausgangsspannung vergleichen.
Also dieses Ding, wo dieses LM339 draufsteht.
Und der kleine IC, der unter dem Fenster war.
Da steht T4C drauf.
Könnte alles mögliche sein.
Und von dem, was ich gefunden habe, ist das einfach nur ein Voltage Detektor.
Also der sieht einfach auch nur, ob eine Spannung anliegt oder nicht.
Wie wir gesehen haben, hat dieses Ding ja Molex Ein- und Ausgang.
Sollte nicht viel kann das Ding ja nicht machen.
Irgendein Chip da drauf.
Irgendwas mit Logik ist ja da nicht drauf.
Ich kann nicht einfach irgendeinen Lüfter anschließen.
Einen aktuellen CPU Kühler.
Weil heutzutage haben wir eigentlich immer 4 Pin PWM.
Oder im schlechten Fall den 3 Pin Stecker.
Aber das passt ja alles nicht dahin.
Und da kommt der gute alte cooler Master Jet CPU Kühler ins Spiel.
Das ist so ein richtiger Klassiker von damals.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, hat er auch den Molex Stromanschluss.
Auch mit zwei Kabeln.
So wie das hier auf der Verpackung zu sehen ist.
Wir haben zwar noch die Möglichkeit hier irgendwas, glaube ich, Lüftergeschwindigkeit einzustellen.
Das können wir gleich noch probieren.
Aber das hier wirklich Klassiker der CPU Kühler Geschichte.
Und da sieht man, das ist wirklich aufgebaut.
Soll so ein bisschen an so ein Flugzeug, Jet, Antrieb, Turbinen mäßig angelehnt sein.
Ich habe das Ding schon ewig nicht mehr benutzt.
Und ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht erinnern, ob das Teil auch so laut war wie eine Turbine.
Das werden wir mal sehen.
Na da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also der Kühler ist da.
Ich meine, es sieht schon mal irgendwie cool aus.
Auf jeden Fall top funktionieren bei so einem 12900K.
Oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Wir werden sehen.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, natürlich der Sticker ist auch angefasst.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ding der aktuelle CPU gescheit kühlen kann.
Interessant, dass er den überhaupt gemountet bekommen hat.
Irgendwie, oder?
Beschrieben.
Jetzt starten wir das Ding und schauen, was passiert.
Oh, die Katz.
Das irritiert schon.
Äh.
Chic.
Der kleine Piepser schien mir nicht so katzenfreundlich zu sein.
Deswegen musste ich jetzt Chic leider erstmal von ihrem Platz vertreiben.
Der Cooler Master Jet CPU Kühler macht seinem Namen auch alle Ehre.
Das Ding ist ja...
Was haben die sich damals gedacht bei den Kühlern, ja?
Aber witzig, ihr hört, also ihr hört den Kühler, aber ihr hört nicht mehr das nervige Piepser.
Das lag nämlich daran, weil der Kühler ein bisschen runtergedreht war von der Leistung.
Das können wir jetzt mal kurz machen an diesem Potentiometer hier.
Also wenn er nicht ganz runtergedreht ist, ist das irgendwie ganz geil.
Moment, das Ding guckt einfach, wie viel der angeschlossene Lüfter verbraucht, oder was?
Und daran will es irgendwie erkennen, wenn der kaputt ist.
Aber dann fängt es so ein bisschen an zu kratzen, wie so ein Walkie Talk, ne?
Und wenn man es runterdreht, dann rastet er komplett aus.
Ist natürlich ein super Design, ne?
Super Idee.
Super Idee, dass man den Lüfter immer auf 100% betreiben muss und ansonsten rastet dieses Ding komplett aus.
Tolle Idee.
Nach wie vor, also es scheint zu funktionieren, dass wenn der Lüfter nicht läuft, oder wir können ja mal gucken, kann ich den anhalten?
Ah ja.
Immerhin, immerhin.
Also theoretisch würde der Lüfter blockieren, dann würde man ein Warnsignal bekommen, dass der Lüfter nicht läuft.
Das ist schon mal gar nicht so schlecht.
Die Frage, die man sich stellen muss, ist, ist das ein Szenario, das tatsächlich in der Realität existiert?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, ob das mir jemals ein Lüfter kaputt gegangen ist.
Die Teile scheinen generell endlos zu halten.
Da könnt ihr mir mal gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Doch, da muss ich sagen, mir ist schon ein Lüfter kaputt gegangen, aber noch nie ein CPU-Lüfter.
Mir ist ein Lüfter auf dem Mainboard kaputt gegangen, bei meinem Athlon XP damals.
War das ein Asus Mainboard?
Und der Lüfter hat irgendwann angefangen, tatsächlich auch zu machen.
Und wollte dann nicht mehr.
Also, das war aber wirklich der einzige, an den ich mich erinnern kann.
...schreiben, ob euch schon mal ein Lüfter kaputt gegangen ist.
Das würde mich wirklich interessieren, weil das hatte ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Ich hatte es, glaube ich, einmal, dass ein Lüfter von Anfang an nicht funktioniert hat.
Aber ansonsten hatte ich das nie, dass einem Lüfter irgendjemand ausgefallen ist.
Und wie das Ganze funktionieren soll, dass der irgendwie merkt, dass die CPU zu heiß wird.
Wie hat er gemacht?
Und dann hat er den Geist aufgegeben.
...von Anfang an klar, dass es ja unmöglich ist, weil hier gibt es ja keinerlei Kommunikation mit diesem Gerät, mit der CPU irgendwie.
Deswegen ist dieses...
Bei Asus gab es damals eine Rückrufaktion von einem Sausbilder.
Da war mein Mainboard davon betroffen. Ja, ich habe einen neuen Lüfter bekommen von Asus dann.
Korrekt. Athlon XP Mainboard.
Ja.
...vor 110 Grad Celsius beschützt nach wie vor.
Das ist absoluter Nonsens. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Aber theoretisch würde mein Lüfter...
...würde mein Lüfter ausfallen, dann würde mich das Ding anschreien und sagen, jo, ich hätte ein Problem.
Also so weit, so gut.
Wie gut kühlt eigentlich so ein Jet, so ein 12900K?
Das scheint auch tatsächlich von einem Flugzeug irgendwie inspiriert zu sein, weil die haben da auch so diese Signalleuchte eingebaut,
die normalerweise irgendwo am Flügel des Flugzeugs ist, aber nicht an der Turbine. Aber okay.
Also, Eideltemperatur passt.
Aber natürlich taktet sich da die CPU auch runter und dementsprechend, ja, passiert da auch sowieso nicht viel mit Abwärme.
Aber wie sieht es mit Cinebench aus?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ja?
Direkt, direkt Limit, ja?
Das sieht ziemlich warm aus.
Ja.
Also wie man sehen kann, Temperaturen sind auf jeden Fall bei den P-Cores direkt auf 100 Grad Celsius.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Also, wir haben hier gerade 70 Watt, was über die CPU abgeführt wird.
Und ja, klar, dass Cinebench ein bisschen zu viel ist, das war mir wahrscheinlich klar.
Ich hätte gedacht, Gaming geht vielleicht auch mit 70 Watt.
Das wird nicht mal für Gaming-Last ausreichen, dass die CPU sich nicht runter taktet.
Ein Highlight muss ich euch noch zeigen.
Und zwar passiert das...
Ich bin wirklich zufrieden mit meiner Wasserkühlung, muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Das ist jetzt ja schon, naja, dreiviertel Jahr oder so, den neuen Rechner.
Erster mit Wasserkühlung.
Das Ding, das Ding tut einfach.
Ich bin da echt, ich bin da echt happy mit.
Wenn wir das System wieder herunterfahren...
Oh!
Okay.
Also, es scheint mir so, dass der Lüfter eben dann früh aussetzt und dann denkt sich dieses Teil so...
Oh!
Das hört sich an, wie dass da gleich was platzt.
Der Lüfter ist schon wieder tot, ich muss wieder rumschreien.
Also, stellt euch mal vor, jedes Mal, wenn ihr euren PC...
Das kommt übrigens auch beim Anmachen.
Jedes Mal, wenn ihr euren PC an- oder ausmacht, schreit dieses Ding hier rum.
Also, nee.
Passend zu diesem komischen Teil hier habe ich nochmal was ausgegraben.
Das ist von Evercool.
Evercool kennt man, die haben so ein paar obskure Kühllösungen.
Und hier haben wir GT365X.
GT365X Extended Cooling System.
Das ist dieses kleine Teil hier.
Und das soll dafür sorgen, dass der Lüfter noch 5 Minuten nachläuft, nachdem das System ausgeschalten wurde.
Denn wenn man hier mal...
Jetzt erst mal schön in Reihe stecken alles und gucken...
Ah, nice Tastatur, die kommt mir bekannt vor.
...schaut, dann...
Nee, das ist eine Corsa-Tastatur, kommt mir nicht bekannt vor.
Ich kaufe mir keine Corsa-Tastaturen mehr.
Ich habe mit der letzten so schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
...steht hier, without GT365.
GT365, also der...
Das ist wirklich, also...
Ich habe mir eine K95 Premium RGB Platinium, frag mich nicht, gekauft.
Da war ich so unglücklich mit.
...schon wieder.
Ihr macht den PC aus und dann sagt er mir, nach irgendwie einer Minute soll der PC nochmal wärmer werden.
Also die rote Kurve zeigt mir, dass der PC warm wird, eine Minute nachdem man ihn ausgemacht hat.
Also...
Nee.
Einfach nur nee.
Und auf der Rückseite ist es auch nochmal...
...detailliert erklärt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich habe mich auch gefragt, wie zur Hölle funktioniert denn das?
Ist da irgendwie ein Akku drin oder sowas?
Aber das wird dann klar, wenn man sich den Text hier unten durchliest.
Denn da steht, dass dieses Ding an 5 Volt angeschlossen ist.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich 5 Volt Standby-Power.
Ah, ja gut, das kann ja noch nachlaufen.
Okay, das ergibt tatsächlich irgendwo Sinn.
Kennt ihr ja, wenn euer System an ist.
Also wirklich brauchen tut man es nicht, weil sobald es aus ist, dann produziert es ja auch keine neue Hitze mehr.
Und über das Passiv-Ding wird genug abgeleitet.
Das einzige, wo ich das kenne, dass manchmal der Lüfter noch ein bisschen nachläuft, ist das Netzteil.
Bei manchen Netzteilen.
Aber ihr habt den Netzteil-Stecker, also hier die 24 Pin angeschlossen.
Und das Netzteil ist einfach nur an, das System nicht.
Dann habt ihr Standby-Power.
Also dass irgendwelche LEDs leuchten.
Und dieses Ding greift vom Prinzip her auf die gleiche Stromquelle zurück.
Also auf 5 Volt Standby-Power.
Und hier unten haben wir das nochmal stehen.
Da sagt dann, dass im Gegensatz zu normalen Kühlern...
Führt das eben dazu, dass nach dem Abschalten die CPU-Temperatur dann weiter sinkt.
Was natürlich klar ist.
Also wenn ihr normalerweise euer System ausmacht und ihr habt hier so einen Kühler drauf.
Dann ist der ja warm und läuft erstmal nicht weiter.
Was ja auch vollkommen egal ist, weil die CPU ist ja eh aus.
Aber die CPU, nachdem es aus ist, wird auf jeden Fall nicht mehr warm werden.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall absolut unmöglich.
Dementsprechend ist ja auch dieser Adapter dabei, damit wir 5 Volt Standby überhaupt...
Wow, das sieht abenteuerlich aus.
...einen Anschluss abgreifen können.
So einen ATX-Zwischenstecker.
Das sieht ja abenteuerlich aus, das Teil.
Das würde ja sehr, sehr schön aussehen.
Und dann haben wir hier unser kleines Auto.
Finde ich auf jeden Fall auch lustig oder verrückt, dass die das einfach an ein Autodesign angelehnt haben.
Warum auch immer.
Und da haben wir jetzt einen Lüfteranschluss.
Der ist wahrscheinlich dafür da, dass wenn man eben nicht 5 Volt Standby benutzt, sondern im Normalbetrieb...
Das Ding sieht wirklich bescheuert aus.
...dass das dann durchgeschleust wird zum Lüfter.
Und wenn es ausgeht, dann irgendwie 5 Volt Standby.
Ich schließe das mal an.
Dann bauen wir dieses Ding jetzt mal final ein.
Also ich habe es soweit...
Da sahen ja F-Zero-Autos auf dem Super Nintendo dreidimensionaler aus, als der Aufschrug da oben war.
...dass es am 24-Pinch-Stecker dran ist.
Habe auch schon den Lüfter angeschlossen.
Und das packen wir jetzt einfach mal an den CPU-Fan vom Mainboard.
Und dann müsste das gleich funktionieren, dass wir das anschließen können, dass wir das starten können.
Bin ich sehr gespannt, was da passiert.
Also passiert erstmal gar nichts.
Außer ich habe es falsch rum gemacht hier.
Das wäre natürlich äußerst doof.
Gleich Monka-Smoke.
Ah, die LED leuchtet grün.
Das war wohl äußerst doof.
Dann...
Lüfter läuft.
Schön.
Immerhin ist es davor geschützt, irgendwie falsch angeschlossen zu werden, ohne dass es gleich anfängt zu rauchen.
Es ist schön warm.
Okay, soweit so gut.
Das hat funktioniert.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wenn wir das System wieder ausmachen, was dann passiert.
Außer dass jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich das Computer umschreien wird.
Der Lüfter läuft.
Er wird jetzt wahrscheinlich zwei, drei Minuten laufen.
Aber eigentlich ist es komplett unsinnig.
Wozu braucht man das?
Das scheint soweit zu funktionieren.
Jetzt ist auch die LED wieder rot.
Also müsste jetzt über 5 Volt Standby laufen, weil ich hatte erst so ein bisschen Bedenken,
weil nicht jeder Lüfter läuft mit 5 Volt.
Also gerade anlaufen ist manchmal schwierig.
Wenn ein Lüfter läuft, mit 5 Volt weiter zu betreiben, kann aber funktionieren, wie wir hier sehen.
Also hält, was es verspricht.
So wie es aussieht.
Ob das Ganze sinnvoll ist oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Weil deinem PC ist es ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal, ob es da drin noch warm ist, wenn man den ausmacht.
Weil theoretisch also eine CPU im ausgeschalteten Zustand, ja, die kann ich nicht ausmachen.
Im ausgeschalteten Zustand, ja, die kann ich auch auf 200 Grad Celsius erhöhen, wenn ich da irgendwas rumlöten möchte oder sowas.
Und das hält die problemlos aus.
Dementsprechend sehe ich jetzt nicht, warum man sowas verwenden sollte.
Aber es hätte zumindest mal, wie versprochen, funktioniert.
Trotzdem sind das aus meiner Sicht Gadgets, Tools, die sich aus gutem Grund auch nicht durchgesetzt haben.
Also von hier der guten Systotec-Marke.
Also beziehungsweise es war ja P-Logic, P-Logic.
Der Fanatic Headshot Pro Controller.
Oder wie hieß das Ding?
Doch Fanatic Headshot Controller.
Hat man nie wieder was gehört.
Evercool weiß ich gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Die haben damals zumindest mal richtig viel gemacht.
Ja.
Tools, die kein Mensch braucht, die trotzdem lustig waren.
Ich bedanke mich für's Zuschauen und mach's gut bis dahin.
Also ich meine, ich meine, Christian danke für den Sub, ich meine den hier.
Ja.
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will, braucht eine Top-Ausstattung.
Und da ist der Fanatic Headshot Controller genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einer ultra...
Ich muss ja machen fürs Lachen, wenn ich das Ding sehe.
Das sieht so billig aus.
So schrottig man.
...präzisen Gamermaus und einem Highspeed-Pad.
Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Das sieht so kacke aus.
Super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen Gamersessions für ermüdungsfreies Spielen.
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein Fünf-Wege-Steuerrad sorgen dafür,
dass Sie Ihre Spielfigur auch in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasma-Gleit-Maus-Füße sorgen zusammen mit dem Highspeed-Pad
für minimale Haft- und Gleitreibung, für schnelles, präzises Zielen im Spiel.
Das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die Quere.
Dafür sorgt die clevere Kabelführung.
Einflüssige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben,
Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
RGB, bevor es RGB hieß.
Viele Gamer sind begeistert von den Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und Tastatur.
Selbst während des Spiels.
Auch Makros lassen sich problemlos einsetzen.
Damit sind Sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der Fnatic Headshot Controller ist das ultimative Set für Gamer.
Und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk gut ankommt?
Probieren Sie es aus.
Ja, natürlich, das ist alt. Guck mal, die Produktion war doch sogar noch in 4 zu 3 Format.
Warum ich das auswendig kenne?
Ne, weil ich schon ein paar Mal geguckt habe.
Wow, wow, wow.
Und auch nur diesen einen Satz.
Der Fnatic Headshot Controller.
Gibt schon tolle Sachen.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Äh.
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Keckel.
iPhone 15, ich konnte es aus...
Oh, ne, ne, ne, kein iPhone.
Jetzt.
Was haben wir denn?
Der Absturz von Diablo 4.
Das wollte ich angucken.
Videos von Maurice sind immer nice.
Und mich interessiert tatsächlich, was bei Diablo 4 abgeht.
Weil ich habe von Diablo 4 seit Season 1 eigentlich kurz den Aufschrei des Negativen gehört.
Und danach nichts mehr.
Und ich habe das mal letztens verfolgt auf Twitch.
Ich glaube, der ist noch bei der Gamestar, macht aber hauptsächlich sein eigenes Ding.
Ähm.
Und es hat halt...
Warum sieht denn das eigentlich jetzt so dumm aus, die Übersicht hier?
Man hat halt kaum noch Views.
Guck mal hier, Browse.
What the f*** is up?
Hahaha.
Twitch, Alter.
Haha.
Oh, Mann.
Buber.
Haha.
Genau.
Danach habe ich jetzt gesucht.
Ähm.
Also.
Mal gucken, wo Diablo 4 hier steht.
Moment, Moment.
Wait a minute.
Diablo 3 hat mehr als Diablo 4?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Hä?
Wo ist denn Diablo 4?
Wait a minute.
Ist das...
Ist das einfach nur Massive?
Recommended for you.
Nein, nein, nein.
High to low.
Aber da war es doch eben.
Hä?
Da ist es.
Okay, 4K.
Das ist halt wirklich nicht viel.
Factorio ist ein mega-nices Game.
Factorio hat wohl eine recht beliebte Speedrun-Szene.
Zwar nicht riesengroß, so wie Mario 64.
Aber es gibt wohl recht viele, die da aktiv sind.
Ja.
Es gibt wohl viele, die da aktiv sind.
Steam Charts.
Moment.
Ist Diablo 4 auf Steam?
Ist das nicht so ein Blizzard...
Stimmt.
Das ist, glaube ich, auf Steam.
Oder?
Ist das...
Oder ist...
Nee, nee.
Ist nicht auf Steam.
Ja.
Das...
Ich habe schon die Space-Erweiterung gesehen.
Nein.
Ich hätte aber echt mal wieder richtig Bock auf ein paar Runden Factorio.
Okay, Maurice.
Dann erzähl uns mal, was abgeht mit Diablo 4.
Ja.
... bekommen, haben die Entwickler verraten.
Und die braucht es auch, denn mit der ersten Season scheint das Spiel ziemlich übel abgestürzt
zu sein.
Ja.
Ich sage scheint, weil...
So kam mir das auch vor.
... Blizzard, anders als zum Beispiel Steam, keine offiziellen Spielerzahlen rausgibt
und wir es deswegen nicht an einer ganz klaren Metrik festmachen können.
Spielst du erst zwei?
Nee.
Aber alles, was so drum rum passiert, deutet doch sehr stark darauf hin, dass das Spiel
ein Problem hat.
In der Community stieß die erste Season auf.
Ich habe es mir nie gekauft, als riesen Diablo-Fan, aber nach Diablo 3 irgendwie und Blizzard
die letzten Jahre über, ich hatte kein Vertrauen mehr, was erstmal so aussah wie, als habe
ich mich getäuscht, weil Diablo 4 richtig gut ankam, so für drei, vier Wochen.
Aber im Nachhinein hatte ich doch recht.
Sehr viel negatives Feedback und auf Twitch ist das Spiel von durchschnittlich 220.000
Zuschauern im Release-Monat.
Auf 2400 im September abgestürzt.
Das sind 99% Reduktion.
Was wahrscheinlich auch daran liegt, dass damals Asmongold und richtig viele große Streamer
gespielt haben und heute halt nicht mehr.
Selbst kenne auch kaum jemanden, der das Privat noch spielt, das ist anekdotisch, gebe ich
zu.
Ich auch nicht.
Spielt ihr noch Diablo 4?
Chat, repräsentative Chat-Umfrage?
Ja.
Wie es bei euch ist, sieht es da ähnlich aus?
Spielt ihr es noch?
Kennt ihr noch viele Leute, die es noch spielen?
In meinem Fall, wie gesagt, ich habe es weggelegt und die meisten Leute, die ich kenne ebenfalls.
Ich finde das auch erstmal jetzt keine Katastrophe.
Ich habe es viel gespielt zum Release, ich hatte viel Spaß damit, es ist absolut okay.
Ich meine, wenn man sich überlegt, ich habe Diablo 2 damals bestimmt zwei oder drei Jahre
gespielt.
Immer wieder.
Aber gut, es war halt online, Battle.net only.
Und ich habe halt hauptsächlich getradet, aber natürlich auch gespielt.
Es gab wenig Games, wo ich so viele Stunden reingesteckt habe, als in Diablo 2.
Dass man nicht so ein Spiel die ganze Zeit durchspielt, habe ich mehr Zeit für Baldur's
Gate, ist doch auch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Was ich übrigens auch gerade streame, TwitchTV, Maurice Weber, ganz toller Kanal, alle reinschauen.
Aber das kann halt nicht sein, was Blizzard gewollt hat.
Also nicht, dass ihr meinen Kanal nicht schaut.
Nein.
Also ich kann euch auch sagen, warum es definitiv nicht das ist, was Blizzard sich vorgestellt
hat.
Letztendlich ist es ein Vollpreis-Produkt mit irgendeinem komischen Season Pass und
Gedöns wieder und kaufbaren Cosmetics und das funktioniert nicht, wenn der Kram nicht
gespielt wird.
Wie lange hast du PoE gespielt?
Boah, bestimmt nicht so lange wie Diablo 2 insgesamt von den Stunden her, aber auch schon
viel.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel, aber paar hundert Stunden sicherlich.
Aber nach ein paar hundert Stunden blickt mir ein PoE ja erstmal durch, was man da eigentlich
macht.
... weiterspielen, denn das Ding sollte ja ein Service-Game werden und soll es immer
noch sein.
Ja, genau.
Ein langfristig gespieltes Spiel, zu dem Leute immer wieder zurückkehren und hoffentlich
dann auch gut Geld im Shop lassen.
Das scheint jetzt aktuell nicht ganz so funktionieren zu haben, wie sich Blizzard das vorgestellt
hat.
Die haben ja mit WoW auch aufgehört, Spieler-Zahlen zu veröffentlichen, als es so langsam aber
sicher ein bisschen bergrunter ging.
Es macht sich natürlich auch immer gut, ja, man kann immer super, super veröffentlichen
so nach dem Motto, neuer Rekord gebrochen, wieder Rekord gebrochen, höchster Spielerstand
ever.
Aber sobald es dann ein bisschen runter geht, macht sich das halt nicht mehr so gut.
Viele Leute vermelden, mit der ersten Season ist die Luft ziemlich schnell raus.
Ach ja.
Ja.
Das ist das genaue Gegenteil von allem, was wir erwartet hatten, denn ich hatte immer
den Eindruck, dass sich alle einig sind, Spieler und Blizzard, dass die Seasons von Diablo 3
nicht ganz genug waren und dass wir ja alle gesehen hatten, schaut mal, Path of Exile
macht das viel besser.
Ja.
Aber Crining Gear Games kriegt auch richtig viel Shitstorm, kann man nicht sagen, ist
es ja nicht, aber auch viel Gegenwind in den letzten paar Jahren, so, also, gerade
was die, viel Hate-Up, ja, also man muss ja auch sagen, gerade was die Performance angeht
und wie oft PoE crasht, es crasht nicht komplett, es lockt dich halt aus, ist schon ein bisschen
grenzwertig.
Und das ist die Messlatte, was Diablo 4 auch pro Season bieten sollte, ich hatte ehrlich
gesagt damit gerechnet, dass Season One ein richtig krasser Paukenschlag wird, der zeigt,
guckt mal, BÄÄM, so sehen bei Diablo 4 die Seasons aus.
Ja.
Und was mit Season 1 passiert ist, sofern ich das als Außenstehender mitbekommen hab,
ist, man hat das Gameplay verlangsamt und alle Skills genervt.
Wie gesagt, ich spiel nicht, keine Ahnung, aber das war das, was ich so, was ich so,
Achso, der sowieso der Tenor war, so durch die Bank weg.
Das Path of Exile, ja, war vielleicht naiv, aber ich dachte auch irgendwie, das wäre der Deal.
Diablo 3 kam mit seinen eher mäßigen, also es gab ja auch tolle Seasons, witzigerweise jetzt gerade die letzten, da haben sie nochmal richtig angezogen.
Aber es kam mit seinen Seasons ja auch gerade deswegen durch, weil es nicht so krass monetarisiert war, beziehungsweise dann ja irgendwann gar nicht mehr.
Und man auch irgendwie eingesehen hat.
Ich muss sagen, was ich an Diablo 3, was mir persönlich, warum ich es auch nie groß gespielt habe, die sind ja am Anfang, hatten sie das ja relativ klassisch mit Trades und Problem war damals halt das Auktionshaus, was halt voll von Arsch war.
Und danach haben sie Diablo 3 umgebaut zu komplett Self-Found.
Für mich, also was für mich einen riesen Reiz an Diablo 2 ausgemacht hat, ist, dass das Spiel nicht, sag mal so, das Spiel war nicht...
...nicht so schwer.
Dementsprechend konntest du halt auch sehr viele verschiedene Sachen spielen.
Du konntest Dual-Wolf-Sperr-Barb spielen und sowas.
War eigentlich komplett für den Arsch, aber ging trotzdem gut mit den passenden Items und dem passenden Bild.
Und dementsprechend konntest du halt, hast du viel Variation gehabt in Diablo 2.
Wenn du natürlich wirklich die absoluten so Min-Max-Builds spielen wolltest in Diablo 2, dann gab es da jetzt auch nicht so viel.
Aber es war cool.
Und, also du konntest relativ viel spielen.
Und für mich war halt der Battle.net-Trading-Faktor extrem motivierend für mich in Diablo 2.
Trading-Channel, kaufen, Zeug verkaufen, wissen, was gerade angesagt ist.
Leider hat es mir das dann ein bisschen den Spaß versaut in Diablo 2, als es diese riesen Dupe-Wellen gab.
Diablo 2 war ja eines der ersten richtig so, nennen wir es mal, massively online Games.
Was sicherlich auch mit den Grundsteinen gelangt.
Und es hat sich dann auch ein bisschen gelegt hat für später World of Warcraft.
Von den Erfahrungen, die man dort gewonnen hat und sowas, garantiert.
Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Ja, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
So, und dieser Faktor hat mir halt komplett gefehlt in Diablo 3.
Nachdem es komplett nur noch self-found war.
Ja, das ist halt dann natürlich nicht...
Außerdem hat mir Diablo 3 auch vom Gameplay nicht so gut gefallen.
...wie bei Path of Exile, wo es mit jeder Season neue Pakete zu kaufen gibt.
Path of Exile ist eines der ganz wenigen...
...Free-to-Play-Spiele, wo ich viele, viele hunderte Stunden drinne hab.
Und gleichermaßen sogar Geld für ausgegeben hab.
Und nicht nur, sagen wir mal, die sinnvollen Sachen.
Ja, zum Beispiel die...
...für die Kiste die Tabs für Essenzen oder für generell Kisten, Kisten-Tabs für Items und sowas.
Das ist ja bei Path of Exile zwar optisch...
...aber es ist ja auch ein bisschen...
...optional, ist aber schon sinnvoll, wenn man das hat.
Ich hab mir sogar Hideout-Skins und so gekauft in PoE.
Einfach weil's geht und ich mir gedacht hab, ey, du hast jetzt so viel Zeit da reingesteckt.
Schadet doch nicht. Kauf halt mal...
Also, das ist das einzige Modell, was bei mir bisher dazu geführt hat, dass ich Geld ausgegeben habe.
...meistens optional sind, klar, abgesehen jetzt von den Stash-Tabs, die bei Path of Exile echt nur so semi-optional sind.
Die sind offiziell optional.
Die sind offiziell optional, aber wenn man das ein bisschen mehr grindet, braucht man die.
Aber bei Diablo 4 hat man sich gedacht, okay, Battle Pass, überteuerter Shop...
Ich mein, niemand muss in PoE die beim Leveln, wenn er einfach mal reingucken will, die Kampagne durchspielen und ein bisschen...
...braucht keine Stash-Tabs.
Aber selbst da ist schon sinnvoll. Brauchst du nicht, wirklich.
Also, du kannst rein, wirklich rein Free-to-Play spielen.
Sobald du dann aber ein bisschen Endgame-Farmen willst und sowas.
Ein paar Tabs sind schon sinnig, aber die Tabs sind auch nicht so teuer.
Und bis dahin hat man ja da schon...
...40, 50 Stunden...
...vielleicht...
...reingesteckt und dann kann man das, denke ich, durchaus machen und man kommt da ganz gut hin, ja.
Also, ich finde das auch eine faire Sache bei Path of Exile.
Ich finde das eines der besten Games in diesem Genre und eines der besten Monetarisierungsmodelle.
Ja, Spooliemann sehe ich genauso.
Nicht so geil.
Der Deal ist dann aber doch hoffentlich auch, dass dafür auch mehr saisonaler Content kommt.
Und es gab mehr als in Diablo 3, ja.
Aber...
...längst nicht so interessante Mechaniken, wie Path of Exile sie bringt und längst nicht so interessante Mechaniken, wie wir uns alle erhofft hatten.
Path of Exile, interessante Mechaniken, ist gut.
Path of Exile ist mittlerweile so extrem vollgestopft mit Mechanics.
Du musst erst mal 300 Stunden gespielt haben, dass du überhaupt durchblickst, was da passiert.
Du hast ja allein schon Endgame.
Der Kompass ist...
Nee, wie hieß das? Map?
Nee, ist das nicht Kompass?
Wie hieß...
Wie hieß diese Weltkartenübersicht mit den Maps drinnen?
Ich glaube, sie hieß einfach nur Map.
Atlas, nicht Kompass.
Atlas.
Genau, Atlas, das meine ich.
Und die ganzen Endgame-Mechanics, weil die haben ja aus ihren alten Ligen oftmals die Sachen drinnen gelassen.
Also du hast dann zum Beispiel irgendwelche Abyss-Dinger.
Du hast dann das Syndicate-Zeug und den Garten.
Und diese Organe, die du da irgendwie einen eigenen Boss kreieren kannst.
Path of Exile ist so vollgestopft mit hunderttausenden Mini-Mechanics.
Eigentlich blickst du...
Also die erste Season, die du spielst, die kannst du nicht durchblicken.
Du musst eigentlich zwei, drei Seasons spielen, dass du überhaupt halbwegs den Plan hast, was da überhaupt abgeht.
Ja, PoE ist null einsteigerfreundlich.
Wobei man das gar nicht so sagen kann.
An PoE kannst du zumindest mal Kampagnen...
Kannst du auch als Einsteiger durchspielen.
Einfach ein bisschen Action-RPG-Crime machen und gut ist.
Aber richtig, richtig gut optimierte Builds und Skills und alles.
Das ist, da ist PoE...
Ich will auch gar nicht behaupten, dass ich da wirklich alles durchgestiegen bin.
Ist schon echt super kompliziert.
Und ein Punkt, wo ich tatsächlich sagen muss, was an PoE echt kacke ist.
Das ist die Kampagne.
Die Story und die Kampagne ist so dumm.
Du merkst richtig, dass die Kampagne immer weiter gesponnen wurde.
Ohne, dass man sich Gedanken dazu drüber gemacht hat, wie es weitergehen soll.
Es ist so...
Also okay, die Kampagne geht.
Ich hab das falsch ausgedrückt.
Die Kampagne in PoE geht schon klar.
Aber die Story von PoE, die ist so unglaublich dumm.
Und...
Und unstimmig und dämlich.
Also die Story ist wirklich hängen geblieben.
Also ich glaube, niemand spielt PoE wirklich für die Story.
Auch nicht mal wer.
Also die Story ist einfach so ein wilder, unzusammenhängender Bullshit,
wie ich das sonst in wenigen Games gesehen hab, die so eine lange Kampagne eigentlich haben.
Also die Story ist wirklich richtig dämlich.
Stattdessen fällt das Spiel weiterhin so irgendwann zwischen Level 70 und 80.
Einfach eine Klippe runter.
Das war ja schon Kritikpunkt zum Release.
Ab da hast du das Gefühl, mein Charakter verändert sich jetzt kaum noch.
Klar, ich erhöhe weiter Stats durch Paragon-Punkte.
Aber ich find wenig Spannendes.
Mein Gameplay ändert sich nicht mehr viel.
Ich mach immer das Gleiche.
Nicht so Magic.
Nein.
Ich hab früher Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt.
Worauf ich hinarbeiten kann.
Wurzel des Problems ist möglicherweise schlechte Planung.
Schon vor Release gab es unschöne Berichte,
dass die Entwickler...
Da blick ich heute auch gar nicht mehr durch.
Die haben ja auch 30 Milliarden Mechanics mittlerweile eingebaut.
Dass du irgendwie 50.000 Schaden machst, First Round oder sowas.
...tief Überstunden machen mussten, um überhaupt das Grundspiel
rechtzeitig zum anvisierten Release-Termin fertig zu kriegen.
Also mal wieder typisch Gaming-Industrie.
Und möglicherweise war das Endgame dann eben das, was als letztes
fein geschliffen und finalisiert werden sollte
und zwecks Termineinhaltung hinten runterfiel.
Season 2 verspricht daran, zumindest ein wenig zu schrauben.
Da soll es Endbosse geben, neue Endgame-Bosse,
mit denen wir dann auch gezielt bestimmte Items,
bestimmte Uniques sogar erfarmen könnten.
Das gibt einerseits mehr zu tun, andererseits auch mehr dem Spieler
das Gefühl, er kann zielgerichtet auf etwas hinstreben.
Das zeigt schon, dass Blizzard das Problem,
ein wenig versteht und Dinge umsetzt,
Das ist ja bei Blizzard auch schon mal etwas, ja.
...zu ändern. Wie gut diese Sachen werden.
Ich meine, habt ihr denn keine Smartphones?
Man sieht, Blizzard versteht nicht immer, was das Problem ist.
...zeigen müssen.
In Season 1 war die Mechanik ja leider auch dann letztlich nicht so spannend,
wie erhofft, obwohl sie coole Ansätze hatte.
Aber das geht schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Das Problem, das Diablo 4 aber im Tieferen hat, ist, dass Season-Änderungen, glaube ich,
nicht reichen werden, um zu beheben, dass sich über lange Sicht jetzt doch rausgestellt hat,
dass das Spiel an den grundlegenden Sachen krank, die wir in einem Action-Rollenspiel machen,
dass die langfristig ziemlich nervig werden, nämlich Looten und Dungeons-Rennen.
Fangen wir mit dem Loot an.
Deswegen muss man Reviews bei solchen Games auch immer zweigeteilt sehen.
Also bei solchen langfristigen Games.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass dieses Game übelst Spaß macht,
die Kampagne zu spielen, und man richtig Bock hat, die ersten 30, 40 Stunden zu criten,
aber man halt keine 400 Stunden darin criten will.
Das weiß man aber zu dem Review-Zeitpunkt noch nicht.
Kannst du auch von niemandem, der ein Review macht, erwarten, dass er erst mal 400 Stunden spielt,
bis er das...
Außerdem, zu dem Zeitpunkt weiß ja keiner, wie sich das in Zukunft entwickelt.
Und der hat das Problem, dass das Spiel dich so zuballert,
mit konfusen, absurden,
überladen, affixen, dass es irgendwann mehr Arbeit als Freude ist, eine Ladung an Beutel...
Und was ich auch gelesen hab, ist, was die Leute richtig abfuckt,
dass du wohl Edelsteine im Inventar, also Gems im Inventar hast,
und die irgendwie genauso viel Platz brauchen wie ein Item.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, hä? Warum?
Ich mein, in Diablo 2 war das doch ganz sinnvoll gelöst.
Diablo 2 hat einen Gem, hat halt einen Slot gebaut,
einen Schädel oder so, hat halt einen Slot gebraucht.
Einen Charme hat eins bis drei gebraucht.
Und Waffen und Rüstung haben je nach Größe gebraucht.
Man hätte ja sagen können, okay, alle Waffen brauchen gleich viel, alle Rüstung...
Okay, das hätte ich... Aber warum braucht so ein Edelstein so viel wie eine fette Rüstung?
Das ergibt für mich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
... in deinem Inventar durchzuwühlen, ob da was Interessantes dabei ist.
That is one big pile of shit.
Da könnten Sachen wie Loot-Filter helfen.
Hat das nicht?
Hat Diablo 4 keine Loot-Filter?
Path of Exile kannst du ohne Loot-Filter gar nicht spielen.
... beheben, dass diese Affixe zum Teil einfach kompletter Quatsch sind.
Ein Beispiel, einfach nur ein Beispiel für Affixe, die es alle separat gibt.
Mehr Kälteschaden, mehr Schaden für Frostzauber,
mehr Schaden gegen unterkühlte Feinde.
Mehr Schaden bei eingefrorenen Feinden oder so was wahrscheinlich noch.
Mehr Schaden gegen eingefrorene Feinde.
Ha-ha-ha.
Wie man es einfach wusste, Alter. Ich kenne das Game nur noch.
... mehr Schaden gegen verlangsamte Feinde,
mehr Schaden gegen bewegungsbeeinträchtigte Feinde
und mehr Schaden gegen gelähmte Feinde.
Das sind alles unterschiedliche Eigenschaften,
die auf Items rollen können.
Niemand will das.
Niemand will sich da durchwühlen.
Niemandem macht das Spaß.
Zu einem gewissen Grad, ich verstehe irgendwie den Gedanken dahinter,
könnte das Tiefgang und Wildschlösser ...
Aha, aha.
Hey, cool, du kannst dich auf einen ...
auf einen Frost-Build mit deinen Items spezialisieren.
Aber Diablo 4 macht das so kleinteilig und gleichzeitig so unspannend.
Und am Ende nehmen wir ja doch Crit und Vulnerable,
weil das für die meisten Schaden startet.
Das war in Diablo 3 schon ein bisschen fragwürdig.
In Diablo 3, am Anfang, weiß ich noch, war Attack Speed ...
quasi der Stat schlechthin der beste Build ist.
Oder ganz am Anfang mit Demon Hunter,
aber es war ein bisschen komisch,
weil es war eine unverwundbarkeitsdauer,
dass man unendlich unverwundbar sein konnte.
Das war auch ganz merkwürdig.
Ich finde, ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr, was ich echt nicht checke, ist ...
Diablo 2, das ist ein Game von 1998 oder so.
Ja, das ist ... Oder wann kam Diablo 2 raus?
Nee, 98 nicht.
Vielleicht ein bisschen später.
2000, ja, Diablo 1 war eher so ...
Naja, zumindest ...
Nee, Diablo 1 muss 96 oder so sein.
Das war ein Game von 2000.
Und das macht's jetzt vielleicht nicht endgamemäßig.
So richtig viel krasses Endgame gab's in Diablo 2 nicht.
Kam dann auch erst später mit über Diablo und solchen Sachen.
Aber das macht, was Itemization, Stats, Inventarmanagement,
Skilltrees und so angeht, das macht vieles einfach besser als Games,
die ...
die, sagen wir mal, 20 Jahre neu sind.
Wo man sich dann denkt, die müssen doch noch irgendwas daraus gelernt haben.
Und das Coole an Diablo 2 war, das konntest du casual-lastig spielen,
weil man's verstanden hat irgendwie, ja,
auch wenn's viele so wirre Details gab, die man dann schon wissen musste.
Aber das konnte ... Diablo 2 konnte jeder spielen.
Es hat jeder verstanden, ja, wenn in Diablo 2 eine Waffe kommt,
die eine Waffe gedroppt hat, die war stärker als deine aktuelle.
Das hat jeder weniger nachvollziehen können.
Ja, und du hast auch an Stats erkannt, okay, das ist was, was ich brauche, ja.
Wenn du irgendwie plus alle Necro-Skills hattest,
da hast du gesehen, oh, geiles Item für mich, ja.
Plus ... plus Attack-Speed, ähm ...
wusstest du auch, okay, Amazon, du hast es sofort erkannt.
Das sind 20 Jahre.
Ja.
Deswegen frag ich mich ja, warum man da nicht gescheit was draus gelernt hat.
Dass dieser Grad an ...
Mein PoE hat's auf die Spitze getrieben.
PoE hat das genommen, was Diablo 2 gut gemacht hat,
und hat so viel drumherum gebaut, dass heut auch keiner mehr durchblickt.
Ah, coole Spezialisierung, längst überschritten ist.
Und wenn du so ein System mit solchen Affixen machst,
dann bräuchtest du zumindest ein gescheites Crafting-System,
mit dem Leute dann mehr Möglichkeiten haben.
Allein schon das mit Runenwörtern, das kam ja erst ein bisschen später,
und mit dem Sockeln über Quests, das waren so coole Mechanics in Diablo 2.
Diablo 2, find ich, hat die perfekte Kombination aus Gameplay,
Tiefe und Einsteigerfreundlichkeit gehabt.
Diese Items ...
Und, und eine, wie ich finde, sogar ganz brauchbare Kampagne,
wenn es auch ... da ...
wenig Story hatte, aber es hatte irgendwie eine gewisse ...
Einzigartigkeit, ja.
... in ihre Richtung zu bringen,
dass es nicht ganz so eine reine Schrottlotterie ist.
Aber das Crafting-System von Diablo 4 ist sehr eingeschränkt,
eingeschränkt als in Diablo 3 sogar,
und obendrein so lächerlich teuer,
dass es auch keinen Spaß macht, ... Das ist auch eine coole Sache an PoE.
... irgendwie die Items noch fernzutunen.
Das Crafting-System von PoE ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Da kannst du immer gut Sachen auffüllen und ein bisschen verbessern.
Und du kannst ... Das wird nie irrelevant,
das Crafting-System von PoE, weil ...
Also, es gibt ja PoE, typische PoE-Sache,
da gibt es mehrere Crafting-Systeme.
Es gibt einmal das an der ...
an dem Tisch quasi, im Hideout,
und dann gibt es noch das ... Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, das ...
Das versteckte Dings ... Syndicate-Crafting-System.
Da weiß ich gerade nicht, wie das heißt bei PoE.
Aber reden wir mal an der Werkbank, das Crafting-System.
In PoE ist das richtig gut gemacht.
Du kannst Low-Items sehr gut enhancen,
relativ günstig sogar,
dass du schön durch die Kampagne kommst,
so mehr Feuerresi, mehr Blitzresi und so, die gehen auch.
So, und dann kannst du halt Items ... Endgame craften,
wo dann so Sachen drin sind wie ...
Blocke ... diesen Stat, dass der nicht random rerollt werden kann,
und dann rerollst du alle anderen, was deine Chance steigert.
Was dann verdammt teuer ist.
Ähm ... Aber das ist richtig gut gemacht in PoE.
Das Crafting-System ist von Anfang an gut bis komplett high-endigste,
absolut top Items, kannst du das gebrauchen.
Ist was Grundlegendes im Argen,
was eher nach einem Loot-2.0-Rework schreit,
wie es Diablo 3 ja auch mit Reaper of Souls bekommen hat,
als, okay, ein paar Season-Bosse und ein paar Season-Mechaniken
werden das beheben.
Und daneben hat ja auch das, was wir tun, einige Probleme.
Nämlich ... Dungeons laufen.
Das ist die Haupt-Endgame-Aktivität,
die beabsichtigt ist, dass wir sie immer wieder machen.
Es macht aber nicht so viel Spaß, sie immer wieder zu machen.
Im Gegenteil, irgendwann willst du sie gar nicht mehr.
Ich finde auch was, das kriegt PoE auch relativ gut hin.
Du hast eine ziemlich vielfältige Auswahl an Endgame-Maps,
die du upgraden kannst, mutieren kannst,
äh ... noch zusätzlich ...
Du kannst ja Maps irgendwie vier-, fünfmal upgraden,
dass da die abgedrehtesten Sachen rauskommen.
Trotzdem ist es recht abwechslungsreich.
Da kannst du verschiedene Gems in deinem Atlas einsetzen.
Es ist gut gemacht.
Es ist wirklich nice.
Da merkt man, da wurde sich Gedanken gemacht.
Auch hier, man sieht Verbesserungen.
Man sieht Erkenntnis des Problems, nachdem ein Patch erst mal kam,
der gefühlt gar nichts verstanden hat von dem, was die Probleme sind.
Mit der erhöhten Monsterdichte machen die Dungeons um einiges mehr Spaß.
Ja, aber ihre Kernmechaniken halten dich trotzdem immer wieder kurz auf.
Und das ist auch ...
Das ist auch etwas, was, glaub ich, niemand so richtig kapiert.
In einem Action-Rollenspiel, wo es um flüssiges Durchmetzeln geht,
warum ist das Spiel grundlegend darauf ausgelegt,
dass ich immer wieder backtracke, um, ah, einen Dungeon-Schlüssel,
eine magische Kugel, ein Knabeltier zu finden,
den ich irgendwo noch in einer kleinen Hinterecke des Dungeons ...
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es in Diablo 4 so ist.
In PoE ist das andere extrem.
Das ist, finde ich, schon fast ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Ich weiß nicht, hat jemand von euch mal
einen PoE-High-End-ausgerüstete Charakter gesehen?
So am Ende von einer Season oder so?
Ich mein, du siehst ja die Monster kaum noch, bevor du weiter rennst.
Du bist im Prinzip nur damit beschäftigt,
deine Skill-Rotation zu machen,
deine Flask-Rotation zu machen
und deine Movement-Skill-Rotation zu machen.
Also, PoE ist quasi zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp,
Map fertig, nächste Map, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp.
Das ist schon fast ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt.
Und warum sind die Albtraum-Mechaniken auch so oft drauf ausgelegt,
dass ich kurz innehalten muss, dass ich unterbrochen werde?
So viele Mechaniken, wenn ich die auf einem Schlüssel sehe,
auf einem Siegel, ach nee, ach, die Donnerkuppel wieder,
hm, ah nee, okay, nee, hab ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, die sollten das Spiel schwerer machen
und die sollten es dem Spieler natürlich irgendwie anspruchsvoller machen,
diese Dungeons zu laufen, aber auch spaßiger.
Und das schaffen die wenigsten dieser Mechaniken.
Da gibt es wirklich tiefere systemische Probleme,
als, wie gesagt, sie leicht behoben werden könnten, meiner Meinung nach.
Ich hätte zum Beispiel riesig Lust
auf einfach einen richtig schönen Endlungsmodus.
Einen Endlos-Dungeon oder einen Endlos-Orden-Modus oder beides.
Hab ich in PoE nie so wirklich gemacht, aber gibt es, ja.
Wo ich wirklich ohne Unterbrechung metzeln kann.
Hilft übrigens auch nicht, dass dann pro Season
auch noch nur eine Handvoll Dungeons
in den Hauptraum-Dungeons werden können.
Damit schöpft Diablo 4 ja nicht mal die Vielfalt aus, die es hat,
weil du diese Dungeons auch so schnell immer wieder siehst.
Nun finde ich, wie ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt habe,
nicht, dass Diablo 4 ein komplettes Schrottspiel ist oder so.
Ich hatte sehr viel Spaß damit und ich finde,
es macht viele der wichtigsten Grundlagen sehr richtig.
Das Kampfgefühl ist wuchtig und spaßig.
Die Atmosphäre ist düster und richtig gelungen.
Die Kampagne hatte viele richtig tolle Momente.
Sie hatte auch ihre Probleme und ich verstehe immer noch nicht,
warum man sie nicht auf Weltstufe 3 weiterspielen kann,
statt da innehalten zu müssen.
Aber da ist viel da, das Spaß gemacht hat.
Ich habe auch nicht das Gefühl...
Ja, Render-Sequenzen, das konnten sie schon immer gut.
...dass ich irgendwie betrogen wurde und nicht genug Spaß hatte mit dem Spiel.
Ich habe Charaktere in der Pre-Season aufgelevelt,
ich habe Charaktere in der Season aufgelevelt.
Ich hatte mit dem Nekromanten, mit dem Auto-Casting-Herz
auch noch mal einigen Spaß in der Season.
Aber es ist noch nicht da, wo es sein sollte.
Es kann auch noch nicht da sein,
aber ich glaube, dass es das ist, was Blizzard will, dass es ist.
Weil ein Service-Game muss, wenn es funktionieren will
und wenn es den Leuten auch das Gefühl geben will,
dass sie hier für ihre Mikrotransaktionen,
ihre Battle-Pässe, ihr Geld und ihre Spielzeit auch genug bekommen,
muss es mehr bieten.
Und ich glaube, bis es mit Diablo 4 so weit ist,
bis es an dem Punkt ist, an dem es sein sollte,
müssen wir mindestens auf das erste Add-on warten.
Es hat das Potenzial für den Reaper-of-Souls-Moment
oder den Destiny-1-Moment, also den Moment,
wo ein großes Add-on viel umkrempelt
und das Spiel endlich an den Punkt bringt,
wo es sein volles Potenzial ausschöpft.
Ich glaube nur, es braucht eben auch ein Add-on.
Eine Season wird nicht reichen.
Season 2 bringt sicher Verbesserungen,
auch Edelstein-Inventar und so Sachen.
Ach ja! Haben Sie das jetzt endlich hingekriegt?
Ist Ihnen auch aufgefallen, dass es eine blöde Idee war,
dass in Jam so viel Inventarplatz braucht?
War noch nicht genug.
Und Blizzard muss sich da anstrengen,
denn Konkurrenz schläft ja nicht.
Path of Exile 2 ...
Und vor allem, es ist enorm schwierig,
das darf man auch nicht vergessen,
Spieler, die man verloren hat, zurückzugewinnen.
Ich sag nicht, dass es nicht geht.
Also, keine Ahnung, so Sachen wie Rainbow Six oder so,
die haben das auch noch mal in die Kurve gekriegt.
Es ist schwierig.
Du hast nur einmal die Chance, einen guten ersten Eindruck zu machen.
... ist auf dem Weg und sieht verdammt gut aus.
POE 2 wird auch Hardcore-Kreisel grindet, wenn's rauskommt.
Mein Tipp ist Last Epoch.
Das ist so ein bisschen diesmal der Underdog in diesem Rennen.
Bisschen das Grim Dawn.
Gut, dass du das erwähnt.
Das hab ich seit, keine Ahnung, 3 Jahren oder so
bei mir auf der Steam-Liste stehen.
Wollte ich mir schon lange mal angucken.
Grim Dawn war damals das zwischen D3 und Path of Exile 1.
Und Grim Dawn kriegt übrigens auch noch eine Erweiterung.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Also, es gibt Optionen.
Last Epoch ist mein persönlicher Geheimtipp aktuell.
Ein Hack & Slay mit richtig coolen Ideen und Systemen,
die ein wenig in Richtung Path of Exile gehen,
aber nicht ganz so krass sind in dem, was sie von dir verlangen.
Es hat aber zum Beispiel eigene Skilltrees für jede Fähigkeit.
Also jede einzelne Fähigkeit
kannst du mit einem eigenen Skilltree spezialisieren.
Was für eine coole Idee.
Das Spiel, wenn ihr gerade müde seid, was Diablo 4 angeht,
würde ich euch empfehlen, guckt euch das mal an.
Das kriegt auch gerade ein größeres Anliegen.
Ein größeres Update.
Meiner Meinung nach auch ein sehr vielversprechender Konkurrent,
der wiederum zeigt, wie gesagt, Blizzard muss mehr liefern.
Ist das noch Early Access? Dann spiel ich's nicht.
Okay, ich spiel's nicht.
Ich spiel's nicht.
Ich kritisiere aus Liebe in diesem Fall.
Ich spiele keine Early-Access-Games mehr.
Ich muss noch auf das erste Add-on warten,
denn die Probleme liegen dann dort.
Selbst bei Lost Gate 3 hab ich mich zurückgehalten,
das Early Access zu kaufen.
Ich kauf keine Early-Access-Games mehr.
Ich hab keine Early-Access-Games mehr.
Alles Fake bei Theostrack.
Nein, wer hätte denken können, dass da was Fake ist?
Das wirkt ja doch so super authentisch schon die ganze Zeit.
Hab ich nie gedacht, dass da was Fake ist.
Warum nicht, Max?
Warum ich keine Early-Access-Spiele mehr spiel?
Weil zu viele Early-Access-Spiele nie aus dem Early-Access rauskommen.
Irgendwann einschlafen.
Ich find, da lohnt es sich einfach nicht, die Zeit reinzustecken.
Ich hab Hunger, so langsam aber sicher.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Programmierer reagiert auf 14 Minuten.
Haben wir da irgendwas Kurzes und Knackiges?
Was ist das?
Can Linux save this outlapped?
Natürlich kann Linux das safen, je nachdem, was du darauf laufen lässt.
Wenn du darauf einen aktuellen Firefox laufen lässt
und willst Web-Anwendungen starten, dann läuft's halt auch beschissen.
Dann ist es egal, ob Linux oder Windows.
Ein Satz mit X?
22 Minuten zu lang.
Das ist irgendeine fiese Ausbildung,
bei Hermes, da wollte ich ja auch reingucken, aber das ...
IQ von 150.
Quasi lebender Five-Hat-Beweis.
Everything in Rust Rewrite.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Mein Magen knurrt schon.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Hast du eigentlich mal in die Windows 11.23.H2 Update-Preview reinge-
Nö, nö, nö, wieso? Lohnt sich das?
Ist da irgendwas dabei, was man gucken sollte?
Wir könnten das im Stream angucken, aber nur,
wenn es da irgendwas Sinnvolles gibt, was sich lohnt.
PC-Welt.
Na, wenn die PC-Welt das schreibt, dann kann das nur geil sein.
Zeig mal her, was gibt's denn da Neues?
Windows-AI-Copilot juckt mich null.
KI-Geschütz-Datei juckt mich null.
Na, wenn das so gut funktioniert wie die Windows-Suche, dann gute Nacht.
Aktualisiertes Design des Datei-Explorer.
Moment, hat das jetzt eigentlich schon Tabs?
Ja.
Noch mal neues Design, okay.
PC-Welt, wie wär's mal mit nem Screenshot dazu?
Dynamische Beleuchtung.
Integrierte Tools zur Steuerung der RGB-Beleuchtung von Geräten und Zubehör.
Okay, das find ich cool.
Ist halt nur die Frage, ob da mein Mainboard-Hersteller,
Grafikkarten-Hersteller und RAM-Hersteller mitmacht.
Aufheben der Gruppierung von Task-Leistungen.
Oh, endlich!
Endlich!
Leute, wir müssen uns das angucken.
Moment, sind noch nicht bestätigt.
Ach so, enthalten.
7-zip out of the box, auch gut.
Das ist ja mal tatsächlich ein halbwegs sinnvolles Update.
Microsoft, was ist denn da los?
Winzig-weich-Window.
Cringe!
Dice of cringe, Leute!
Neue AI-Funktion im Mail juckt mich nicht.
Sicher Wiederherstellen von Apps.
Okay.
Neue Einstellungen, Startseite, HDR, Desktop-Hintergrund-Bilder.
Aktualisiertes Menü für die Sauna.
Überarbeitete Apps für Notepad und Snipping-Tool.
Copilot ist wohl die aufregendste Neuerung.
Quatsch, geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Entgruppierbare Apps ist viel wichtiger.
Ach, so sieht der neue Explorer jetzt aus.
Okay, Leute, ich würd sagen,
das müssen wir uns heute Abend vielleicht mal angucken.
Windows 11, 23H2 hieß das, gell?
Ja.
23H2 hieß das, gell?
23H2.
Bing Daily Image of the Day.
Ja, das wär mal ganz cool.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab keine Hoffnung drin,
dass der Explorer das jemals gut kann.
Windows 10, wahrscheinlich Windows 11 auch noch,
hatte das Problem,
dass wenn der Desktop voller Icons ist
und du das Task-Menü gestartet hast,
dass es geleckt hat.
Das ging dann, wenn du es schon ein paar Mal schnell auf und zu gemacht hast,
ging es einfach für vier, fünf Sekunden.
Macht es das?
Bann. Ja, Bann müssen wir uns auch noch angucken.
Es ist aber nicht,
ob ich da Hirnkapazitäten heute für hab.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
ich würde nie mit meinem Arbeits-PC da reingehen.
Ich würd mir das einfach parallel in irgendeiner VM installieren.
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Aber können nicht alle.
Und wollen auch gar nicht alle.
Hab ich mir auch nicht vergessen.
Ich bin happy mit meiner Kombination aus Lieblings-Möglichkeiten.
Ich hab auch Lineux für fast alles
und Windows für Gaming und Videogramm und Streaming,
zumal ich einfach umschalten kann zwischen zwei Desktops
und dann habe ich Lineux im Fullscreen
und Windows im Fullscreen.
Easy.
Zack, Windows Full Screen,
Linux Full Screen,
Windows Full Screen.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
und wer hat so ein geiles Terminal,
Images anzeigen kann.
Sogar animierte GIFs.
Pogu.
Pogu-Turm.
Der Turm-Champ.
So.
Chat.
Jetzt ist es soweit.
Jetzt gehe ich was essen.
Ratet mal, was es heute gibt.
Ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Äh, what the fuck?
Jawohl, es gibt Nudeln mit Lachs.
Du brauchst die Wallpaper.
Dann geh auf GitHub.
Wobblos White Paper Happy Desktop.
Und da findest du für jede Tageszeit
einen passenden Wallpaper.
Sogar Workout-Time hier.
Und wenn du Linux verwendest,
kannst du entweder mein Skript
oder Skript von Max verwenden.
Was dir automatisch alle 10 Minuten
den Desktop changet.
Oder du benutzt, setzt manuell ein Bild.
Oder du nimmst das Desktop-Change-Software
deines Desktops oder so.
Egal.
Also die Bilder sind alle hier drin.
Images.
Und falls jemand ein neues Hintergrundbild braucht.
Ich hab gehört, der Rackman lässt sich da bestechen zu
im Discord.
Aber immer unter der Auflage,
dass das Bild open sourced wird
in dem Repo.
Gibt es für Windows ein Skript?
Nee, bis jetzt haben wir noch keins.
Geben tut es das bestimmt.
Und wahrscheinlich ist das mit PowerShell auch relativ easy machbar.
Also wenn es dir danach ist,
lass dich aus.
Und dann packen wir das auch ins Repo rein.
Gibt es bestimmt.
Mich würde sogar wundern,
wenn es das nicht sogar schon fertig gäbe.
So Leute, ich hab mega Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was fressen.
Bis denn. Wir sehen uns.
Und hören uns.
Wir hören uns. Wir sehen uns eigentlich nicht.
Ist eigentlich Blödsinn. Wir hören uns nur.
Bis denn. See you.